- The thing about this
like frail Asian kid
wearing a beanie walking around.
You look like a fucking cancer patient.
(Joey laughing)
So I was like, "I'm tired of this,
I wanna change my style."
- Right?
- Lemme get there, right?
So I went for the skinhead look,
(chuckle)
I looked like a complete...
(laughs and claps)
I look like I just came
out of prison, right?
(bright upbeat music)
Hello and welcome to another episode
of the Trash Taste podcast.
I am your host for today, Garnt
that is a real name I can assure you.
(Joey laughing)
And I'm joined today,
with my cohost Connor and Joey.
- The ones with the real names
- Real actual names.
- The actual real names.
- Me, the wisest man on earth.
( Joey laughing)
- So by the time this comes out,
this would have been very old by now
but we haven't really got a chance
to have, had a real debrief
on our cycling special.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- Because we filmed an outro
and that turned out to be 26
minutes or something like that.
And we were just like,
people gone
- originally.
- Yeah. Originally people, we were like
people don't wanna hear us
talk about a special day
they've just seen.
- Yeah, by the way,
If you haven't watched
the cycling special,
- Yes.
- You should go and do that before
we're gonna talk.
we talking about that video.
- Yes.
- So if you wanna watch
that link down below or top
- On screen now.
But I think the biggest thing,
I mean obviously the reaction for that
has been absolutely,
- I'd say awesome.
- Awesome.
But what I found funny was,
how seriously people took
when it came to discussing
who won and who lost and who cheated.
- Yeah.
- In that cycling special.
- There was, I've never
seen like our subreddit turn
into like just the most like, "No you"
- Top of like thread
- It was a fucking
free for all for a good
period of time there.
(Connor laughs)
- It was like fucking team Garnt
and Joey versus team Connor
battle is this like--
- Is this how the twilight
fans I'm wearing the prime?
- Yeah.
- Yeah I mean I get it you
know, they they're invested
- They invested
- I appreciate it, you know
- Which is a good sign,
which is a good sign.
- Yeah.
- Yeah but I mean okay,
I think I'm very like,
I'm very fake salty,
like I'm always like, fake angry.
- I think we are all fake
salty and fake angry.
(Joey laughs)
- But like in real life as well
I'll get like,
I'll start like getting like,
I'll sound like loud I'm
like, "Yo this is fucked up"
and then I'll be like,
"oh you really count
like no, no, not really.
( Joey laughs)
Am just like ,I just like
getting annoyed about things
in a way that isn't like,
- Right.
- Twittering.
- That's very British of you.
(joey and Connor laughing)
- Yeah yeah yeah British, very British.
Am so like I can't believe this!
Oh my God really like, no.
I don't wanna do this shit
- Like no.
- I mean like , you know, the cheating.
I was like at the moment,
I'm sure when I found out
you cheated I was like,
"motherfuckers."
and then I probably just
thought through like
alright well.
- Yeah yeah.
- But then obviously,
'cause there's also clips
said like me talking
about it on my live stream,
but obviously like I play up the saltiness
cause I it's good to
showmanship, you know.
It is. Its fun.
- Yeah. But it's unfortunate that like
a large majority in the internet
doesn't understand sarcasm.
- Dude that was so I, there was like
an all subreddit people discussing.
- Yeah.
- Who cheated, who really
won, who is the real winners?
- Who done it?
(laughing)
- And I there's just one comment,
I can't remember what it was called
but they were like big man Connor Cahoot
thinks he's a real winner, real chad huh.
Connor's friends,
cheaters when he cheated,
and he was getting so angry about it
and I was like what the fuck?
(laughing)
- And it was so funny seeing how like,
the fact that there were so many people
who are infinitely more
saltier then we are like,
we didn't give a shit like
- What its like now it's like to us,
it's we make the video, we film it.
- Yeah.
- If someone cheats you know,
and it makes for good content
then its make for good content.
- Yeah yeah yeah
- I mean originally I remember
going on a cycling special
I think I, this got cut out the video
but I remember telling Connor.
Yeah I'm gonna do the whole thing because
(chuckles)
you know I,
- Its pretty wild time.
- Even if I don't,
when I'll feel good if
I do the whole thing.
- Yeah.
- And then so the fourth
challenge happened
and then Joey suggested the cheating
and I just thought to myself
that would make for a
really funny segment,
if we can actually cheat.
- That's exactly what it was
it's like yeah sure, you know
saying that "oh I wanted to
take a fucking free car ride"
like you know,
- I'd be lying if I
say I didn't want that.
- Yeah.
- But ultimately
I was like, no, no, no let's do this
because it will make for
great content and it did.
- It's not about the race
it was about the friendship.
(laughing)
- It was about the friends
we lost along the way
(chuckles)
which is apparently each other.
(laughing)
- True true.
- No, because like I feel like, you know
there's a difference between
obviously none of it was scripted,
which we don't script what
happens on the specials,
but we all still, you know, we all
we do still have that voice
in the back of our head
that says this is going to be content.
- Yeah.
- People are gonna watch
this for entertainment and--
- Cause let's be real like,
you know there was a
part of me that was like,
you know, I'm sure
there will be some level
of entertainment factor if
hypothetically all three of us
with no excellence whatsoever...
- Yeah.
- Completed everything
from start to finish.
But, you know, it's the little
bits of unexpected drama
that makes for an interesting--
- Its the drama, its the banter,
I feel like that's what makes
for the interesting video.
- Yeah.
- And I feel like part of this discussion.
It's like we laugh at it
because we know we
didn't take it seriously
but I'm glad people were that
invested in our contents.
(Joey laughing)
- Yeah man.
- To really go balls deep
to really like break down
the levels of cheating.
- Yeah yeah.
- And like okay I had like I swear
some people could make a spreadsheet
of like every little thing that we do.
- Such that--
- No its like thesis papers.
(laughing)
- It's like the dream cheating thing.
- Yeah yeah.
- People gonna start
hiring like astrophysicists
who cheated technically
I though I got that.
- It was a one in seven trillion chance
that Garnts chain would
break at that very moment.
(laughing)
- There was one call and I was like
why didn't Garnt just
put the chain back on?
I did think that, was like did Garnt,
why didn't Garnt just
put the chain back on?
- Actually this wasn't,
there's a lot of my,
you know, trying to fix
the chain did get caught up
but it was like completely
lodged in there.
- Yeah yeah.
- So like, the reason you
were waiting so long for us
was because I was like trying
to unlodge this fucking chain.
- Yeah.
- And then like I got it back on
and then it came off again immediately
and I was trying to figure out
what the fuck was wrong with my bike.
So I had this like half
an hour to 45 minutes,
where I realized that I
had gone the entire cycle
without first gear.
So the reason that the
reason the chain came off
was because when I went
to the highest gear.
- It just slipped off.
And...
- Yeah, these bikes were very cheap.
- Yeah and like I realized why
I was suffering so much now
on the fucking hills was because.,
(laughing)
- You were in second gear.
- You were in second gear the entire way.
- I was in second gear the entire way.
- I also love though how like
there was so many comments
even on the video being like,
"oh man this seats are too
low, the bikes are too small."
It's like look, that was the
biggest bikes they had there.
- Those were the biggest bikes
and I think I did adjust my seats
to be the highest it could be.
- To the highest.
(laughing)
- Because these people are
designed for Japanese people
- Yeah.
- Because we didn't buy the bikes
there were the rental bikes
from the locaL bikes place there
- We had to fly it to the
other side of the country.
- And so we couldn't bring bikes with us
- These bikes were definitely not suited
for six foot foreigners that's for sure.
(laughing)
- Speak for yourself Joey.
Five foot gang over here.
- But even for your size it was small.
- It was just maybe okay for me.
- Yeah.
- But I'm really pushing it.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- Like it was...
- Yeah 'cause I remember I put my seat
all the way to the top I was like.
- Yeah.
- Oh no this is the highest
it goes I'm gonna fucking die.
- Okay we're pretty fucking dumb, right?
- Yeah.
- We're not that dumb.
- But I saw comments that were also like,
"did they ever use any gears?"
I'm like bro you know, you would know
if we didn't change gear.
Cause Garnt would not be
moving up any of these hills.
- Yeah yeah.
- You think Garnt could
pedal at six gear up a hill,
are you kidding me?
- I was already suffering
enough on second gear
let alone fucking sixth.
- Like some people pretend
like it was the first time
we ever saw a bicycle
with gears like that day.
It's like, "what are these things?"
(laughing)
Lets just leave it alone.
- I didn't realize until I
saw the footage actually,
how much of a clown I looked with like,
this fucking mini bike.
- You do look like a fucking clown.
(laughing)
You did look like a clown.
- With one massive legs,
just like peddling along.
- You're basically like one
of those like the kid bikes,
they're like young and
they're like sitting.
(laughing)
by the feet are going like over here,
like that's what you look like.
- You're like kneeing yourself
in the rib cage every time.
(laughing)
- I was.
- Oh man
- Bad dude squalts every time.
- Oh man I'm glad people
enjoyed it but man,
just it's not that serious guys.
- Yeah.
- It was just a little bit of fun.
- I mean there was a lot of like fluff
that got cut out, shout out to Mood On,
for editing that and going through.
Jesus! How much footage did we have?
- A hundred hours footage Joey.
- Like a hundred hours between us.
Cause it was like we had the six Go Pros.
- It was like one terabyte of footage.
(laughing)
- We had six Go Pro's,
four, so two Go Pros
between each of us
and then also the Handy cams and whatever.
- The drone.
- The GoPro in the camera.
The GoPro in the carrier as well which is,
that's why it took so long.
We filmed that in October,
that's why the production took so long.
For our next special we
probably won't like scale up
until we have like a super super big idea
maybe try something a
bit smaller, you know.
- Yeah.
- For our next project.
- I feel like at this rate
it's just gonna get like bigger
and it's gonna turn into like
a mist a beast tale Dante.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- If we don't scale back a little bit...
- I mean cause we the ones
mainly arranging this as well
so we have to come up with
all the equipment we needed
to figure everything out,
and so like it's quite a
lot to do it for all of us.
- Yeah, like I kind of realized this
when we were doing the thing
and then Connors tire popped,
and every comment was just
like, "wow, I can't believe they
didn't plan for like a spare
tire or something like that."
And yeah in hindsight, it sounds
fucking stupid, doesn't it?
(laughing)
But you have to understand
that most of our planning
went into how the fuck are we
going to power six Go Pros.
- Yeah.
- On our bicycle when we have one car
and none of us near each other.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- So we were trying to figure out
the logistics of trying to get this films
and that's where...
- The last thing we're
expecting was a pop tire.
- Yeah yeah.
- Yeah these bikes were like extra heavy
cause we had like duct tape
the shit out of stuff to it
like that was like portable batteries.
- Yeah.
- Strapped to these bikes.
- Its like a brick
- Just to like keep the Go Pros on.
- Yeah.
- And also Go Pros as such
the fickle things are amazing
when they work but the
moment like there's any heat
they just stop working.
- Yeah.
- yeah.
Because we realized this
during the drifting special.
- Yeah.
- Because people look at
this content and think,
that they don't see the
fucking effort and logistics
that goes into this.
Cause I didn't think about this,
until I had to go out and film it.
- Yeah they just think,
"Oh just buy some cameras and
attach it and turn it on."
- So with the drifting special
a lot of Connor's footage just got lost.
- Yeah.
- Cause like,
it's a shame.
Cause like, the one when I was
doing like the sick donuts.
- Yeah.
- Like all of that footage
was lost 'cause the GoPro
just overheated in like five minutes.
- Its 900 degrees inside the car.
- Yeah because it's an oven in that thing
and mine turned off,
luckily yours guys work.
- Yeah.
- And mine kept dying
in the second half.
- Yeah.
- Yeah it's just sucked
cause like all you get
to see as an outside shot
it doesn't even look like I'm in the car
doing that fucking the thing
and you missed all like
me getting hype screaming.
- Spoiler it was a stunt dog.
- Yeah.
- Exactly, like that's what it looks like.
It could look like a
stunt dog I so said like
that's my drift, that's mine.
- Like I recently watched
this horror movie with Sidney,
I don't remember the name it's
a Korean horror movie right?
- Yeah.
- But the premise of this horror movie,
is that there's this company who basically
does live stream content, right?
And so this company
hires a bunch of people
from the public to live
stream going into this like
haunted asylum.
- Right.
- And you know live streaming
there experiences there.
And,
(clears throat)
so I was watching this movie
and they had this like jank
set up with some Go Pros
that were apparently like live
streaming to this base camp
that was like a literal camp.
- Yeah.
- That they had set up outside
this mental asylum Right?
- Yeah.
- And when I was watching this,
I couldn't get invested in the movie
cause I felt like that guy doing like,
"YouTuber reacts to
YouTuber movies," Right?
And all I could see in
the back of my head was
they these Go Pros don't
even have any spare cameras,
(laughing)
fucking lie there they
were like live streaming
for five hours or something like that.
- Two out of 10 not realistic.
- Yeah yeah there's no
way that would work.
- Yeah.
- Also, how are they getting
signals in this mental asylum.
There's no way the stream
would be this clean,
while they were streaming,
quite inside of it.
- Inside 5G twitch backpacks.
- Exactly.
( Joey laughing)
- Where are they, they didn't even have
the fucking 5G Twitch backpacks.
Like this is fake movie, two out of 10.
(laughing)
- Oh my God,
I mean I like to do something
like that but like just,
you know, the the fucking
effort it would take
to just try and organize the
technicalities behind that
just sounds like a
nightmare in and of itself.
- Yeah, I mean to me
twitch like IRL streamers,
they're just built different
I don't know like...
- I don't have the duo man.
- I think you have to be
another level of like masochist.
- Yeah.
- I think to me it seems like
why would you wanna just
be embarrassed in public?
- Yeah yeah.
- Like constantly.
- Yeah.
- But I don't mind doing it
for a video every now and then.
- Yeah but like having it constantly on,
'cause at least in a video
when you're out there filming,
when you're out and about they're filming,
at least you can like edit it
so it's the most interesting things
that happened on the day.
But if it's an IRL stream,
you see everything.
- Yeah.
- And it's just especially when you're not
even in the safety of your own home either
you're out there in
public people can see you,
people can judge you.
And to me that's just a level of like,
that's the dystopian future
that I don't want in my life
I don't know.
- Yeah.
- Not to...
- Oh go on.
- Oh just saying like not to mention like
in Japan especially where
people already fucking
way too wary about filming and pumping.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- So I don't know how you can just like
rock up to an Izakaya full of people
and just be like, yeah I'm just gonna put
this camera here and just
start talking about our dream.
- Yeah I don't know I
couldn't do that either
I don't know I haven't tried it.
but like I don't know how I would get
over that mental barrier, of just going
into around restaurants,
like having the phone
in front of me and just
talking to the phone.
- Am too British I can't do that.
- Yeah.
- The thought of going into
just a place and doing that is like, what!
- Well just like on the street as well,
I don't get like J Vagus for instance,
can like just be walking on
the streets by themselves.
- Yeah.
- Just have a camera like this
and being like, alright guys
so we're gonna go to blah blah-blah-blah
and just have people staring
at you the entire time.
- Yeah I've done that and it looks like
a fucking hostage video,
I'm like fucking talking
down to the camera like--
- Yeah like I would go like,
I would go like this.
- Yo what's going on people
- But some people just like yep, hello?
- Hello.
- The giant selfie stick out,
yo this is everyone in EK
Bokuto right now check it out.
Like, I don't know I
mean to me, it's like,
and I watch some of these IRL streams,
so I'm quite interested in it myself
and I think like oh maybe
I could do it sometime.
But then when I watch
it I'm like okay cool
they did like one cool thing in the day.
And the rest of it, like a lot of the time
they were just being like
sitting there asking that child like
what's you just want to do?
What's you just want to do?
what should we do guys?
And it's like alright.
And then everybody get what the appeal was
cause most of the time real
life is pretty fucking boring.
- Yeah.
- It was kind
like traveling or waiting.
- Yeah exactly.
- I think though,
- What's the fun.
- In this day and age,
I feel it's a type of content
that is like really sold after all.
- Maybe right now I can understand that,
but before that I'm like
why would you wanna watch
someone just kind of like wait
and sit around all day
and maybe do something
interesting for one hour.
- Because its like you'll really there.
- I get it in COVID times though.
- Isn't this some kind
of like black mirror as,
(laughing)
okay that we're getting oh no like.
I don't wanna have a day myself
I'm gonna watch someone else have a day
and I'm gonna give them money.
- It's like, it's literally
that fucking meme image
of you know that kids sitting
in front of the poster
and being like every podcast they like.
(laughing)
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Its like really what that is.
- The meme just keeps getting
posted on WhatsApp right.
- That's literally what that is.
- Cause like for me like I feel awkward,
if I have a hands-free
sets and I'm just in public
and I'm on the phone.
- Yeah.
- Yeah yeah.
- Like sometimes,
I'd have a hands-free set
and I have the phone up to my face
to look like I'm talking on the phone.
- Yeah yeah.
I do exactly the same.
- As opposed ,
as opposed to just
talking to myself I dunno.
- Yeah cause the other day
I had to go by like some
like eyelashes for Rocky.
- Right.
- So I went to like
the local local pharmacy.
- Yeah the local pharmacy and I was like
fuck I don't know which one she wants.
So, I tried to like take some pictures
and send it being like yeah
pick out which one it is.
And she just fucking calls me
and he's like, just show me.
(laughing)
- So I had to like,
flip the camera.
- Bitch show me.
- And I'm just doing this,
(laughing)
while talking on a hands-free set.
And these all women are looking at me like
what the fuck is this guy doing?
( Garnt laughing)
- They pretty understood
during the eyelashes.
- Just like filming eyelashes
and being like which one.
(laughing)
- I don't know why I find
like only IRL content is
where it feels little
black mirrorly to me,
a little weird I don't know why.
Like no other type of content
- yeah.
makes me feel in that weird kind of,
this is like no other content
makes you feel like this is too far.
Like IRL, just something about it
sometimes I'm watching it I'm like.
Why is this weird?
- Well because I,
I feel that like,
If you stream in like say
a studio like this, right.
There's like a performative side to it.
- Yeah.
- It's almost like a stage
or like a setup for all.
- Yeah like there is literal sets
that's we perform in like this.
- Yeah
- Yeah yeah.
- But sitting down for like three hours
at an Izakaya wall like
having a casual beer,
that's a little too realistic.
- Do you know is well like I saw
a lot of them like a lot
of them get like drunk
a lot of the time and that's
like the audience loves that.
- Oh yeah.
- They love it when they get drunk
'cause they're like,
Oh they could fuck up,
they could say stuff like.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So the audience
constantly eggs them into
drinking even more.
- Yeah people are drink and people are
like waiting for the
next like string fail.
- And this is, and I'm like fuck
that's a horrible relationship to have
with your viewers.
Where they just wanna see you
fucking, fuck everything up.
- Its probably why like most.
- Yeah. I mean,
I feel like even though,
even though you're
it's an IRL stream, you
know, when we're streaming
we do have this performative side to us
that we just talked about.
- Yeah.
- That we feel like we wanna be,
well want something interesting to happen
or we at least want an interesting
conversation to happen.
So I feel like it's a very, I
dunno like unhealthy kind of
like relationship to have with
your viewers at that point
because you have your best interests is
for something to happen.
So you are in this performative side
and I've talked to a few IRL
streamers who have done things
on their streams, which they
probably wouldn't have done
if you know, nobody is watching.
- Right. Yeah.
- Yeah, you defiantly
like fake confidence.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- In the stream watching you.
- Exactly.
- I mean,
isn't that way like the
whole generalization of like,
you know, fun bases of IRL
stream is being like supper...
- Pretty fucking toxic.
- Toxic yeah.
Like I know a couple of viral
streams in Japan as well.
And you know, they're all lovely people.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You know, off stream.
- But I think it's because of the fact
that they have this
really toxic and you know
quite aggressive type of audience
that loves to egg them on.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- To make them do stupid shit
or, you know, fail in some way
that they kind of get dragged into that.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And they, you know, hate to say it.
A lot of them on-stream turn
into a bit of an asshole.
But that's also because you
know, you have thousands
sometimes tens of thousands
of people being like,
"Yeah do this thing that makes
you look like an asshole"
for our entertainment.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It's kind of unfortunate, its like
you know, if you're being
an asshole, you know
that your audience is enjoying it
and the acting you want and you can,
you can almost get lost in the fact that,
"No, I don't think I'm being an asshole.
I think I being entertaining."
- Yeah.
- Right, right. I think so.
- But then, you know,
you see them when you talk
to one-on-one you realize
Oh, they're actually quite normal.
- They nothing like,
they are on the screen.
- They nothing like this.
They're really nice most of time.
- I don't know. Yeah,
maybe I'm overgeneralizing.
I don't know.
I haven't met many, but
the ones I have met a very
different how they act on strings.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, yeah.
I only really know like a
few who will like exactly
the same, but I feel it's a rare breed.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. But, I feel, I
completely review with like
IRL stream content being the
black mirror kind of content
as opposed to any other stream kind
of content in my opinion.
And I'm not sure why maybe
it's because it's you
it literally is like kind
of like a slice of life.
- [Conner] Yeah.
- Where it's, it feels a bit too intimate.
- I feel especially when
it's those IRL strings
where it's like it's not the
camera pointing at the person
but it's like shot in POV.
- [Garnt] Yeah. Yeah.
- Like that shit especially is like, Whoa.
(Joey chuckles)
- It's weird.
It's just, it just makes you think like
where's he gonna go from here?
- Yeah.
- Like what's the next step?
Cause there's gonna be a next step.
And like, I'm just.
- It's only going to one up itself.
- Yeah. Yeah.
which is why I'm like, I
wonder where it's gonna go.
Like, it's just like,
it's really interesting.
- Streaming my wife's pregnancy.
- Kind of scary.
- Obviously, I could see that happening.
- You know what you mean?
- Streaming my child's birth.
- Yeah.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Streaming my child's conception.
- Dad reacts to childbirth.
- It's like, there's fucking...
- Oh there it is.
(Joey laughing loudly)
- There's families on YouTube
that have like more kids
cause more kids is more click bait,
if I can say its click bait.
- Its more content.
- Oh my God.
I just got reminded of that video.
You found the other day Connor about the
the What's up, what's
in your bum challenge.
(laughing loudly)
- Yeah actually, I follow
like Justin Wang on Twitter
I don't know if you follow Justin Wang?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- These man fucking...
- He loves retweeting
the most kush shit ever.
- This man fucking retweets
and posts the kush shit.
And I thought this has got to be a troll.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But there's literally
a series on YouTube
with people being like,
"is that a dildo or a dick in my ass?"
(Garnt and Joey laughing loudly)
on YouTube.
No joke.
This isn't a joke.
I know it's disgusting.
And like I watched it.
Cause I was like,
this can't be right.
- I thought it was just meme.
- Yeah.
I though this is like,
- I thought it was a meme.
This is like no way this on YouTube.
This was like the canned
Goku Pete AIDS meme.
that we thought that. we
thought was just a Photoshop.
- Yeah. And then you go
in and you have a look
and they're like literally
he's fucking doing it.
And I'm like, "this is on YouTube.
What the fuck?
What is this?"
And then they're just
like, he, "oh yeah, I think
that's your Dick."
( Garnt and Joey laughing)
And it's like, "What is happening?
What world are we in?
This is insane."
- Yeah.
It's just like that moment
of disbelief where you just
you can't quite believe
that this is this kind
of content has just, we've
gotten to the point where
we can post something
like this on YouTube.
And it's just, it's not
even a meme like before.
- We went to fucking like
equals three to this shit.
What the fuck happened?
What happened?
Who came up with the genre?
It's a genre.
More than one people is doing it.
- Is it an actual genre?
- More than one person
has done this challenge.
- It's like a dead ass just
like YouTube challenge.
Like pass It on.
Tag the next creator who's
gonna do on you once on
my bum challenge.
- And before someone was like,
" Oh dude, cause it was like,
Oh, people are gonna be like,
bro, cause you're saying,
cause it's like dudes doing it, no.
- If it was fucking women
and guys doing it too.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] No.
- Its fucking weird.
- [Garnt] It doesn't matter.
- why is it on YouTube?
- I think what killed me was just,
how straight they were playing it.
- Yeah.
- There wasn't any irony.
No, there wasn't.
There was zero irony.
There was zero like sarcasm
and what they were doing
they were just like, "Oh
I think it's your Dick.
But I don't, I can't trust
my bumps anymore." Yeah.
- Listen, please don't watch this.
It is literally what I..
- It is the most curse, one
of the most cursed videos.
- Its so fucking cursed.
- Another we went from like, you know,
reaching into a box to see
what it is to just like,
let's replace the box,
- Yeah remember fine
- but with the anus.
Remember when fine bros or TV shows like,
is it jelly or a spider?
(laughing loudly)
- Is it a Dick?
- Is it my dildo or my Dick?
I'll never tell.
- I can't wait for the next step.
Which is like, which operation
are we performing on you?
Is it a for vasectomy or a colonoscopy?
You tell me.
And he's like,
"Oh, okay. I think I'm being like,
my penis is being surgically removed."
What is happening?
The fuck?
How, can YouTube crack down on dump shit?
And just leave this up.
This is insane.
I couldn't believe it.
- Is it the mouth?
- I was...
- Oh or a vagina,
sponsored by Tenga.
(laughing)
- I was...
- Like where did we go from here?
(laughing)
- Yeah like,
so you did the video where
you reviewed sex toys.
- Yeah.
- But we didn't actually like...
- Yeah, its not like you're
under the table, you're like,
"Oh, this is fantastic.
This is rather lubricas.
- Yeah, its not like,
I went up to Garnts like, is it a tango?
Or is it my mouth?
(laughing loudly)
I'll never tell.
- I feel like there's a clear line.
- Yeah.
- In which shouldn't be crossed.
- Honestly like when, so yeah.
For those of you who don't know,
Joey did a video where we
review Sangha products.
- Great video, check it out.
- Great video, great video, great video.
I found it funny cause
Joey didn't really tell me
what we were doing until
the day of filming.
- Yeah.
- So in the back of my
mind, I was just like,
"Is Joey just gonna make me
like go behind a curtain."
And just like, fuck this shit.
Am like, what am I doing today?
I like how possible we got in this shit?
(indistinct chattering)
Cause Joey was just like,
yo, you want to go test out some tangles?
And I'm just like, yeah, sure.
In what capacity are we
testing them out Joey?
- Just boys hanging out.
Just another night with
the bros. You know.
- Another cold one one with the boys.
(laughing)
- Fucking jokes.
- That's a great video.
- We didn't do that by the way.
- Yeah,
- I just can't believe that
video got made, like that had to
be like filmed edited at
no point in the process.
People think is this too much?
- No, the thing, it wasn't
just a one part series.
- It was multiple.
- It's a multiple part series.
And it obviously did really well
because everyone just can't believe.
- Obviously it did pretty well
Cause who's not gonna
fucking click on that.
When you see that.
- It's actually...
Like it's so absurd
you're gonna be like, what is this?
This can't be real.
Oh my God, it's real.
Don't watch it. Don't.
- Please, please.
Please do not,
- but it exists.
- Do not watch this.
- I've never felt dirty.
Just looking up at YouTube
typing something into my
YouTube search history.
- I did watch a little bit of adult...
- I did too.
- And it was fucking hilarious.
Like I just found a really,
- Yeah you'd be great on porn hub.
Great. Funny jokes.
Funny, funny.
- It feels in porn hub,
Fantastic meme, fan-tastic meme.
On YouTube, you're just like,
how are they getting away with this?
- Yeah, how's the law beyond me?
- What is so, what is
okay, moving out of this?
- Please.
- Like what is, what is
some of the most curse
you have seen on YouTube?
I'm actually curious now because I know,
- That's probably the,
honestly the most courseily I've seen.
- It's pretty cursed.
- Its pretty fucking up there.
- I mean that, that is
definitely up there.
But.
- I mean, if I told you like
classic, like coast content
like...
- You guys ever watched,
you have watched like pizza time?
- No.
- You haven't seen that one?
- No, what's that?
- It's this video from like,
Oh, I don't even know when it's made
but it's basically these
like a bunch of dudes
like you watch teenage
mutant Ninja turtles, right?
Yeah. You know how they're
like obsessed with pizza.
- Yeah.
- So it's basically
like a shit post on that
but it's basically this
like explaining it.
It's so weird, but it's basically just
like a bunch of dudes dressed
up in Ninja, turtle cosplay.
And then they like whip
out their like fake dicks
and like jerk off onto this like pizza.
(laughing)
- What?
- Have you not seen it?
- No.
- This is on...
- This is on YouTube?
Fuck YouTube.
(laughs)
Well, I gotta know, are they Australian?
- No.
- American?
- I've no idea.
No, the video was silent.
That's the most coolest thing about it.
- What?
- Yeah.
- The entire video is silent
and it's easily the most.
I don't even remember where,
- Choose your own sound track.
- Yeah, I don't even remember
when I fucking saw it.
but like it was one of
those like, you know
fucking course content
that made his rounds.
Like, you know, it's like fun
spin and that kind of shit.
Right. But it was on YouTube instead
of its own dedicated website.
- feel like I already have intention
- Don't look it up by the way,
please don't look it up.
- Don't see it
as often as the way it used to be.
I don't know.
It used to be like kind of
a like bonding experience
and you'd watch cursed content.
But now it doesn't feel that much.
Now just things like, I feel
like everyone thinks you're fucking weird
if you watch that shit.
- I mean, it's, it's kind of true.
(laughing loudly)
That doesn't matter if you
do it on your own or do it
as a group.
It's still weird.
- Yeah. I mean, it's it's, I mean,
I remember when YouTube went
through the point where
pretty much you can
you can say anything was a prank
and just like, and just get
away with it.
- Fuck the prank thing.
- Like just, just
just physically assault
someone and call it a prank.
- The fuck was his name?
No, Sam pepper.
- Oh God.
- Remember that guy?
- Yeah.
What was it?
He used to be an IRR streamer.
He did a prank where he did like
- Yeah. He killed his best friend. Yeah.
- Wait, what?
- Remember that?
Have you seen that one?
- So he did a prank
where he would kidnapped one
of his, two of his friends.
- Right.
- And then he would pretend to kill one
of them in front of the other friend.
And it was a prank
- And I was like just a prank.
- Are you serious?
This is thing.
Yeah serious.
- This is a huge deal.
Yeah. Huge.
People, people were honest also about it.
- Apparently so, that's,
- That's pretty fucked up.
- And it's like, in the video,
like you just see this like,
this dude like in a fucking
like bag over his head
just like getting fake shot.
Right.
- What?
- And, and the guy, this
is a black mirror episode.
There's no way this is real.
- And the other friend is
like strapped to the chair,
breaking down, crying.
And he's like just a prank bro.
- He just thought his
best friend got murdered.
So of course, naturally
your natural response
is to freak the fuck out.
- Just mentally scared
my best friend for life.
Just the prank bro.
What?
- Honestly, it was fucked.
- Reminds me of that,
like the recent news
that broke where someone
actually got shot or
got murdered in America
or something because they were
filming like a prank video.
Right.
- Oh that's right
- And they were like approach.
I think they were like
fake mugging people.
- Yeah. That was it.
- Really?
- Yeah. There was,
I can't remember the
exact details of the story
but that was his kid or something
who like was just pretending
to mug people or like yeah.
- How do you pretend to mug someone?
I don't know.
- I just go up to the knife
play the YouTube brought
to you through duh.
- Am taking,
- Make it louder on the speaker.
- I'm taking your money.
(laughing loudly)
- There's a guy on the back ground like...
- I mean you know,
I think that's unfortunately
more than one body in.
And now when it comes to YouTube pranks
gone wrong or whatever.
- Wait, wait.
So what happened to the
guy getting like pranked?
- Well he went up to some guy
and the guy fucking
pulled a gun and shot him
cause he was trying to mug him.
- Oh my God.
I mean really.
So I mean, it was self-defense.
I mean he's fucking right,
what's going to happen?
- I mean, it's just, to me,
it seems so you're literally
in America, everyone has a gun.
- I mean, it's not even just in America
in any fucking country,
what can you expect?
- Any country you just
pull a fucking knife out,
other than just getting beat the fuck out,
I'd be like, oh forgive
me, am not doing it.
- This episode is sponsored by Ritual.
- We deserve to know,
what we're putting in our bodies and why?
- You're right.
Rituals, clean vegan-friendly
multivitamin is
formulated with high quality nutrients
in bio available forms
your body can actually use.
- Damn!
- Boys. Do you know what you won't find?
- What?
- Okay?
Sugars,
- Yeah.
- GMO's, major allergens,
synthetic fillers
and artificial colorants.
- Oh my God!
That is insane.
Plus guys, plus the fresh
taste and delayed release
capsule design make
taking your vitamins easy.
- Get out of here.
- This is what have been waiting for.
I want everything to be easy.
Like Ritual.
- Guys ritual is designed
with your life-stage in mind.
Now available for women, men and teens
ritual multivitamins are
scientifically developed to
help support different life stages.
- Don't forget.
Ritual is also made it traceable.
You'll always know what
nutrients you're taking
and where they come from.
Thanks to Rituals one of a
kind visual supply chain.
So get your key nutrients
today without the BS.
Ritual is offering you our listeners
10% off during the first three months.
So visit RITUAL.COM/TRASHTASTE
to start your Ritual today down.
I see what they did that.
- I see what they did.
- I see.
- Thank you to Ritual for
sponsoring the episode.
Back to the show
- Speaking of our souls online
and people acting like assholes online.
- Yeah.
- Going back to the cycling special.
So we've we've I mean, we've
it's funny how we've talked
about like online privacy.
So, so much on this podcast.
- Yeah. We've we've talked about it a lot
and sometimes I feel like
we're beating a dead horse
because we're just like yeah. You know
we have a lot of crazy stories.
- Yeah.
- So it, it kind of surprises me
when there are still some people out there
despite how many times
we've talked about it.
Will do some, not pretty, not cool stuff.
Yeah. I mean, so if
if you haven't been following
my Twitter, so yeah.
Someone tried to leak some
monk photos that I had
which were private
on my mom's Facebook and
know, I mean, I, I said this
I said this on my Twitter
longer, but you know, I
I purposely didn't release
it because you know, it's
I'm fine people knowing that I was a monk
meaning that aspect just, you know
meaning the knowledge or whatever.
But I was just like, I
kept that part private
because you know, there are
like quite intimate photos.
It's like a religious ceremony.
So I didn't, I didn't
want that part of my life.
- Cause when you were in
initially told the story.
I remember after it,
you're like, yeah, boys
I don't wanna share a photo.
- I'm pretty sure he said it on the clip.
- Did you?
- Like I'm pretty sure on the clip.
We were like, I think
one of us said like, Oh
we'll put the pictures
and then go was like, no
I don't wanna put the pictures.
- Yeah. I think I might've said that.
- Maybe its been awhile.
- Its been a while.
I remember it being like
you didn't wanna share the pictures.
- Sure, I understand.
And it's, you know, it's become a meme.
I'm completely fine with, you know
being the monk has become
a meme, but yeah, someone
someone literally stalked
my mum's Facebook, which
you know, it's, there's, there's
there's a difference between, you know
if I fucked up and you know, I
there's some part of my
private life that, you know
I forgot to private, you know
send an move, but you
know, as a public figure
you can expect that people
are gonna try and dig
into your past something like that.
- Which is fact in and of itself.
- Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, it's we, you
know, we can talk about
that fact that we kind of slipped that
but you kind of do have to expect that
but it just felt dirty that
someone tried to stalk my family
especially like my close family.
- That's actually fucked.
- Yeah. And like, these are
really old pictures as well.
So they would have had to go back years
and years worth of like,
my mom's pictures died.
She had creepy to think
someone's just scrolling.
- How bored are they?
- I don't know.
And, and like, all this,
all this for a meme.
(laughs)
It's like, I'm like all
this for like a single meme.
- Well, the person knew that
they were being scummy as well.
They even like self admitted
that they was like scummy.
- Yeah. I know this is a scummy low.
It's like, no, because I, I
feel like, you know, we, I mean
we literally talked about
this last week where, you know
the barrier of privacy between reality
and what's entertainment is like slowly
slowly drifting apart
and slowly being erased.
And I don't know, it feels
weird, funny experiencing
that for myself and
being in the crossfire.
- Yeah. Sucks.
I mean, I had to like tell my parents.
I was like, you know
cause luckily my parents, you
know, they're mega boomers.
So they, they think
that Facebook is the play
you can always have, but yeah
so they never signed up to it.
But I still have to tell them like, listen
if anyone asks you questions about me
or like anything private about
me and try to get anything
just tell them like,
okay, don't answer it.
Just tell them to ask me.
Like, if, even if it's like you know,
Like someone claiming to
be like a government agency
which like, I think somebody,
I can't remember who
called them up.
And asked somehow got my
parents' number or something
and like tryna ask them
questions about me.
And I was like, don't,
don't answer anything.
Yeah. You know, if the police want me,
the police will find me.
- Right. I mean, it's not
like don't parents, don't
anyone who claims to
be anything don't fucking
tell them anything.
It's sad that you have to do that.
Right. I like the thought,
I think it's just really sad
that I would rather be harassed
like a hundred times personally
than my parents be harassed once.
- Yeah.
- I mean I just couldn't
- Cause they got nothing to do with it.
Why then ask them to get involved.
Right.
- It's hard enough raising
me as it was. Right.
Like the way I learnt.
- The little shit that you are.
- The fuck that I was.
I don't wanna have to give them extra work
after they're trynna enjoy
retirement. You know?
So
- It it's, it's been kind of
funny seeing the transition
between like my, my parents leaves
cause my parents were like
really technologically illiterate
and I've had to basically
teach them everything.
But it's been funny seeing
the transition between them
like not understanding social media at all
and just like not using it at all.
And then transitioning that
to like transitioning that
to most of my family now use Facebook.
But remember when Facebook was
just like a cool kids thing
and like the parents,
parents didn't get it.
- My parents still, they
still take it that way.
(laughing)
- They still think it that way.
- Yeah. Cause it was really funny.
Cause I remember one day, cause
I, you know, I've, you know
we are all grown up on the internet
and especially I've been doing YouTube
and social media for like a long time.
But one day my mom phones
me up and this, this was
this was when I had stopped
using Facebook by this point.
And I'd like, most of
my online life has gone
to Twitter because that's
my job and everything.
But my parents had just
started really getting
into Facebook and you know,
being, being that, being
that parents who, you know,
tag, tag you in everything
comment on people's photos,
you know, properly involved.
- Yeah. Yeah.
And I remember she phones
me up one day and she goes,
"Garnt, someone left a mean comment,
on one of my photos.
What do I do?"
I'm just like, "what'd you mean mom?
What, what'd you mean?
What do you do?"
And she's like, "ah, I
don't know what to do.
It makes me feel sad.
I kind of want to reply."
And I'm just like, mom do not.
(laughing)
Do not do this.
Do not reply right now.
Do not get involved at this.
- That's the one thing you should not do.
- It was just funny because,
because like years ago she's like,
she's like, you know, just,
just ignore all the mean comments online.
It just don't worry about it.
As you know, as the parents
do, because you know, as
as someone, as, as a
parent watching a kid does
the social media and do
YouTube, you just don't get it.
You see comments.
You're just like, these
comments don't mean anything.
Right. But it was funny seeing
seeing my parents who had
never been into social media go
through the same cycle
that we had to go out.
We had to go through being like, what
what is a mean comment?
Why are people commenting
mean things on me?
This doesn't make sense.
You know what?
I'm gonna reply.
I'm gonna give the trolls
everything they want.
- At least your mom wasn't like,
"do you know the number
to the cyber police?
(laughing loudly)
I need to report a crime."
Like my mom's like, my
mom's really smart about it.
Like, cause she's been using
do you know about this
website called Mixi?
I don't think it's an annual brand anymore
but basically it's like,
it's really old web.
It's basically like the
old Japanese version
of like my space or like
Facebook and stuff like that.
I don't even think it's around anymore.
Basically. My mom's been like using that.
So like she's had a pretty
good understanding of like
you know, privacy can
be very easily leaked
on the internet if you not careful.
So like, my mom has openly
told me, she's like, yeah
I follow you on Twitter and Instagram
but you'll never know
which account is mine.
- Fuck that.
(laughing loudly)
That's some death note shit.
She's like,
(Garnt laughing)
- Like she just uses like
a completely separate name
and like doesn't use any
photos and stuff like that.
And I'm like, I'm glad that,
you know, she understands that
you know, if she used
her real face a name ,
that could lead to a
whole lot of problems.
Meanwhile, my dad is like, you know
fucking openly comments on
my videos and being like
- That's my son.
(laughing loudly)
That's my boy.
- No, I remember one time.
He's like, did you see the comment
on my latest on your latest video?
And I'm like, no, I get,
I get thousands of comments every day.
And he's like, Oh, okay.
I'll, I'll send you a screenshot.
(laughing loudly)
And it's like, and he's
like, "Oh you might've it
because I don't use my name on it."
But instead he didn't use his name on it.
Right. It's like a completely
different username.
But I knew immediately it was my dad
because the comment starts with, "Hey son"
(laughing loudly)
- That was pretty good.
- "Hey son, I really liked this video.
The editing was done really well."
(laughing loudly)
He's like, "you'll never know it was me."
I was like, "Yeah. Yeah. Sure dad."
- That's so fucking wholesome.
That's so fucking wholesome.
- Yeah but the problem is that like,
when I was still using
Facebook back in the day, like,
you know, again
like my mom would use a
completely like separate name.
Right?
So like, you know, it
was fine or whatever.
But my dad would not
only use his real name
but would also comment on
every fucking thing I posted
always starting with, Hey son.
(laughing loudly)
- So like,
- Hey guys, Joey's dad here.
- And so like, I had to like
and so like one day he came
in being like really upset
at me being like,
"Why'd you block me on Facebook son?"
I'm like,
"cause you keep fucking, stop commenting.
Stop opening a comment with, Hey son."
(laughing loudly)
- Your dad sounds like such a fun guy.
- He's a great guy.
Don't get me wrong.
But like I had to, I had
to literally block him
on every social media.
Just because, he kept fucking doing that.
And now the only,
- The number one harasser.
- Yeah.
And now the only way I can get in contact
with my dad is, get this through email.
- Email.
(Garnt laughs)
- You don't have like
a number or something?
- No. Okay I have his number,
but like, you know, obviously
because it's international,
costs a bit of money, right?
And so I was like, Hey dad, you
should start a line account.
Cause everyone in Japan has line.
Everyone in my family has line.
Right. It's like, if you guys don't know,
LINE is like, you know, Facebook messages.
It's just a messaging app
that we use in Japan a lot.
So I was like, you should start LINE.
And he's like,
"Oh, I don't wanna start
another social media son."
And I'm like, "dad,
it's not a social media.
This is just a messaging app."
And he's like," all right.
All right, fine. I'll do it."
And so I added him and I messaged him
and I was like three
months later he came back
being like, " hey what's up son?"
So I was just like, I was like, all right
I guess I'm just sticking
to email now with my dad
if my dad ever needs anything
I'll just be like, just email me.
- It's urgent.
I've got to email him right now.
- Urgent. "Hey son."
(laughing loudly)
- Now every one of your comments
on everyone of your views
is gonna sound like, "Hey son."
- I mean, that's good.
- I love the Tenderloin.
- No. I guess that's good then.
Cause then now we'll truly
won't know which one my dad is.
(laughing lodl;y)
The comments section is
all going to be my dad.
- He's going to have to try
and find something like
a new phrase to go with.
- Hey boy, Hey boy.
I love you, dad.
I'm just joshing.
Well, were we talking
about internet privacy?
- I guess internet privacy.
I mean, I don't know,
like I've, I've never
I guess this is the
first wake up call for me
that I've had to really think
about my internet privacy.
It took me way too long
to make my Facebook,
my Facebook privates.
That was, that should
have been the first stage.
But, I think the problem with
internet like celebrities
or whatever nowadays is
that there's a difference
between say it's,
you know, someone who's
signed to a big film
or someone gets picked up by music label
like old school celebrities
who there was this system
by which they got picked up
and they knew they were
going to be famous.
But the problem is
anyone can be famous now.
Anyone can have their
privacy leaks and you know
not really think about the
consequences of really going
through their entire past
and just making it private
or making it not public because
we were, we were teenagers.
We don't remember every
sites that we signed up to.
Oh my God.
Like, I dunno how many,
one of my like old forum
like old anime forum
profile pictures are still
like public or whatever, you know?
Cause I signed up to a lot
of sites back then
because I was a teenager.
But I it's, it's something
that you don't really think
about when you don't make
content on the internet
because you don't no one
really expects to be famous.
Well, no one really
expects to have an audience
or anything like that.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And I feel like I, I do wonder
if like the newer generation
is gonna think about this when
whenever they do anything or
if we're just gonna
continue to be stupid kids.
That don't really think about anything.
- I wouldn't like to, for
it to be the first option,
if I'm being honest, just
cause like you know, again,
it's like, I think that
whole prenotion of like,
yeah, you know, you, you should expect
your privacy to be, you
know, hacked and slashed.
- Because,
- people shouldn't be that
that weirds me out.
- It's like, what is it about
suddenly being, you know
quote unquote famous, you know
regardless of how you
view, you know, fame to be
where it's suddenly like,
Oh, well, you know, you
you have a presence on the internet
that you share openly
with a large audience.
So that means that you know,
you don't have a privacy.
If it's on the internet,
it's not private anymore.
- It's literally like the same argument as
like old school paparazzi.
Have you ever seen any fucking interviews
with like any paparazzo photographer?
It's the most,
- They're all assholes.
- Yeah. It's the most like
you would see these people
openly being assholes and they're just,
they're proud of it.
- Yeah.
- They're fucking proud of it.
Like I think I remember the
last one I saw was I think,
Anthony's like sitting
down with a paparazzi .
- Yeah. I saw that one.
- Literally everyone he interviewed
was just the biggest classy asshole.
- yeah. Because, you know,
they do the whole bullsihit of like,
"Oh, if I don't do it
someone else is gonna get it."
And it's like, how about
none of you fucking do it?
And then it sucks.
Cause like I think,
And I'm sending people
again who are watching this
are like super chill.
Don't think like that way.
All it takes that 1% just
to make your life hell.
- Yeah.
- Like, and that's unfortunate. Right?
Cause you know, I don't, I
don't have any resentment
to mine, like audience
or anything like that.
It's super fucking nice.
- Exactly.
- Its just a shame that
some people are just like
I'm a fucking ruin this man's life.
- Yeah.
- It's a shame that, you know
you have to change your
behavior for literally 1%
of the people watching you
and you know, that most
most of everyone that you interact
with is just going to be a
generally nice cool person.
- Yeah.
- And then it just sucks that
there's that small percentage
that unfortunately it's
that small percentage
that ruins it for everyone.
And it's I guess
I guess that's just the
world in general, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. But you know, we'd be living
in a Utopia if everyone
was being honest in,
- Flying cars
- With lying cars by
now, that's not the case.
Some of us are still
walking on the ground.
So yeah.
- A bit sad.
- I was, I was watching this
video they're there and it was
like some blues clues,.
- Blue squats?
Trust me.
This is really okay.
Sorry. Did you watch Blue's
clues when you're growing up?
- Of course what's blues clues.
All right.
- What?
- So, blues clues is TV show
and it was basically this guy,
who was like talking to the camera,
kind of like Dora styling.
This is where it started
this kind of style.
And maybe he didn't know, but
I'm definitely popularized
- Yeah popularized.
- Where they would be like a, a task.
And there was this, you know, a notebook
and they'd have to do
extra amount of tasks.
It was a really good show actually.
- And there was a dog called Blue.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- And so the dog would help Steve?
- Steve yeah.
- Steve find all the clues.
Right.
And yeah.
So I always wondered, I was
like, why did you stop doing it?
Cause if you, if you watch the show
he basically swaps
halfway through the show
with another actor.
I thought, "Oh, that's weird.
Why, why did that happen?"
So turns out that he was losing his hair
and that he didn't want to
like go bold on like TV.
Right. Right.
- Okay.
- So, and then I was like fuck!
That hit me.
I was like, oh my God, fuck!
Cause like, I mean okay,
there's like tons of comments about it.
And it's like, it's frustrating.
Cause like, I don't really give a anymore.
Like I've gotten over it.
But like, unfortunately
my dad did not give me
a lucky dice roll with my genetics
and I am going bald eventually.
It's gonna happen.
And obviously it's been
happening a little bit
and it's so frustrating
that people will like go
to other videos and be like Connor.
Yeah. "Did you know you're balding?"
and I'm like,
- Pointing it out
- And it's so frustrating.
Cause the thing that bothers
me is that like, again
like I fully accepted that it's happening.
I know people are gonna be
like, have you tried doing this?
Have you tried fucking doing voodoo?
And it's like, yes.
- Try doing voodoo.
- Cause people are always
like, Hey, just try it.
like, Hey man, just
take these drugs, do these things.
It's like, honestly like done
all that, tried all that.
- Yeah.
- Unfortunately, like I
can't do surgery either.
So whatever.
And so I just kind of got to
the point where I was like
all right, I think I've
tried enough things
where I'm like this fucking sucks.
Yeah. But can't really do much about it.
Right. Yeah.
And so I kind of got over it,
but it's really frustrating.
Like I said, when people go
to other videos and be like
bro, you're balding.
And it's like, yeah.
Like, like I I'm, I am
aware, but it's frustrating
that sometimes I have to
like edit videos differently.
Cause it's like, all right.
If I don't edit this part out,
people are gonna comment about this
instead of the fucking video.
- And only comment about that
- Yeah. Its like, I just
wanna focus on the video.
And it's so frustrating that
feel the need to point it out.
Cause it's like why?
Right.
- Yeah. I mean, I, I
know exactly how you feel
because I too have not been
too luckiest with my gene pool.
So, like literally,
- Joey I envy you, perfect hair.
- So Joey, like pretty much
everyone on my dad's side,
who's a male.
- Same with same.
Yeah. It's kinda sucks.
- I Mean it's something
that I knew was always going to happen.
- We don't think its gonna happen.
- I mean like as, as like when you're
when you're a teenager,
you're just like, Oh
it's like, I'm, I'm, I'm the exception.
(laughing)
- Cause your hair like,
when you're like 18, your hair's like,
- Its lash.
- Fuck man, my hair is so thick.
- Thick as fuck and like
you think I'm the exception.
And I remember, you know, I've seen
like my entire family on my dad's side.
Everyone's bold, so I asked my dad,
I've seen like pictures of
my dad when he was young
and he had hair down to here, man.
- He's bad.
- Yeah. He was
- Oh he had drip.
(laughing)
- But yeah, I, yeah, he had
a, he had a lushest of hair
and I saw what it looks like now.
And I'm just like,
'so dad, when did you
start losing your hair?"
Just out of curiosity.
So just so I can take a look
and take a look at my own hair
and he goes, "I guess,
late 20, 30 year old."
And I asked this when
I was 28, I was like,
"Fuck dad, why the hell you
did not tell me earlier,
for fuck sake."
- This is like, I can't,
I had a, I had a feeling
It's probably gonna happen to me.
But like, I didn't like quite know.
But then I realized, okay
my older brother is like
10 years older than me.
He's going bald.
And I was like, Oh shit!
Am starting to sweat a little bit.
- See the prior example.
Yeah.
- And I like, you know what?
I totally get why kids
think it's funny to like
mock hair lines because
you just think like
its never gonna happen to me.
Yeah. I've got hair.
My hair is fucking luscious right now.
That's never gonna happen.
But it does.
Oh yeah.
What is it like fucking two
out of three, especially
if you're whining.
I think two out of three
men get like some signs
of hair loss or what happened.
But I remember like I thought, okay,
if it happens to me at 30, no biggie
by then I'll probably be chilling out.
I'll be settling down when
I was like 21 or like 20
I started to notice just a little bit
it's getting a little
bit thin and I'm like,
what's going on there huh?
Am gonna put time out to that.
- So, even when I was like 20,
I started like trying to
do things to like help it
and just, you know, doing
those, like, you know
taking it all the fucking FDA
approved, all that bullshit.
- Yeah.
But unfortunately
for some people it is
purely just genetics.
You just fucked.
Yeah. You just like some
people that helps and like
you know, you do a lot of
research, you look into it
some guys you might be
in a place where maybe
the building you're living
in is like really bad case
of like damp or something.
Its fucking with like your hair or stuff.
- Right.
- So some people who, you
know, their living condition
is the reason why they
are losing their hair.
But yeah, no, unfortunately as much
as I wished I could do something about it
it was just kinda like whatever.
And it's it's yeah.
I guess the, the main reason
why I just thought fuck it.
I'll just talk about it.
Cause it's like, I've
gotten to the point now
where I just don't really give a anyway.
- It's it's like, it's not gonna stop.
I feel like if we just say something
especially with the audience, right?
Like it's going to come
into being like, Oh
this is the inside meme, but okay.
I'll add onto it for the millionth time.
- Yeah Cause you know,
It's like unfortunately,
it's just kind of a
thing of like, you know.
It's just something that I
can't really do anything about.
And unfortunate people are gonna see it.
Cause I'm not like I'm not
unfortunately am not gonna,
- You're not gonna wear a hat every day.
- Just me statically
in front of the camera.
In my head.
- You can't go anything further
than like a 90 degree angle.
Otherwise that's a red zone.
- It was like
so when I dyed my hair
blonde, it wasn't that bad.
Cause my scalp is like white.
So it didn't look that bad.
But it's when it stops scale Brown
and certain lighting,
especially studio lighting
fucking reflects that shit
where it doesn't look too bad.
If you look at me like normally
in like video where the
lighting is washed out
it looks fucking awful.
And it's like, I see it on video.
I'm like, fuck! Its that bad?
I check it.
I'm like, Oh, it's not too bad.
Yeah. But I'm pretty
much at peace with it.
And I'll pretty shave it at some point.
Cause I kind of want to see how it looked.
- Yeah. I reckon you good.
You have you, have you lucked
out though in that regards?
Because the one thing no, no, no.
Like the one thing is like,
you know, like the fact
that you've already accepted
that you're probably
gonna go bold and then you
probably get to go to whatever.
But the at least the
good thing is is that you
can grow a beard.
Yeah. There was nothing weirder
than a dude who is bald
and has a clear face.
- Bro, why are you pointing
my boy, Johnny Shim, man.
Come on, man.
Let's go.
The biggest Dick in the unit.
- Yeah, sure.
And you know, and that's
why he looked like, you know
I can't say that in front
of Johnny shims right.
Cause he probably smack
the dick across my face.
But like, you know, at
least like, you know
a beard on a bald guy
usually nine times out of
10, it looks fucking great.
- Yeah. True, true.
Your card is fine.
- Dude. I appreciate you trying
to gas me up here Jay. Yeah.
- But like, it's weird
because like, you know, you
you said like, you know,
I'm jealous of you Joey
but like I actually had
the opposite because like,
- I have too much hair.
- Too much hair, what a problem guys.
(laughing loudly)
- No, hear, Cause like your
entire dad's side. Right?
- Like, I think my dad
was born like fucking 20.
- Yeah. See, my mom's
side is exactly the same.
Cause my granddad went bald at like 24.
So for the longest time
in my like early twenties,
my mom and my sister would
just egg me on being like,
when you gonna get that hair?
You better enjoy that hair
while you still have it on your head boy.
- All that hairline's receding a bit.
- I would like.
I remember when I was like 18
I asked my granddad being like
how old were you when
you like started to fall?
And he was like, Oh, like, like 23.
And I was like, I was like five years.
. But you know, obviously I
at that point I was like,
look, if I go to bald, fuck it.
I'll just accept it.
You know?
Like I rather just like
shave it all off, then
like leave it half-assed or
I, so I'm just like, fuck it.
- The more I thought about
it and the more cause I
I can't actually get any surgery, even
though I wanted to cause
like a blood condition
the more I thought
about, I was like, do I,
do I really want to
just fucking desperately
cling onto this?
Like at the end of the day, I was like
I don't really think I
give that much for a fuck
where I think I need my hair to function.
Like I think I'll still
be fine without it.
- That's the thing.
Right? It's like people
like, I don't understand
why people are so,
- Well people make it seem
like, if you lose your hair,
its gone because it's
like a bold person, right?
I sleep.
So I'm a full hair, I sleep.
Balding free real estate for bullying.
- Come over.
- Come over its where its happening.
- Yeah. I don't know.
Cause people, I feel like
people just wanna have like
at least some comments out there.
I feel like, then need to
have like a one-up on you.
They don't feel
like they can mock you in some way.
- But they keep mentioning it like,
if you lose your hair,
you're not funny anymore.
- Since when was making
fun of like certain
to do like genetics.
Its like a fucking slam
dunk to me, I was like,
- It's like you know, you take
the piece out someone's look.
No, no, no too far, balding
oh free real estate.
(laughing loudly)
Like he gets the same thing
When you taking a piece
someone was born with like
I do notice like as, you know
as someone who went through
the phase of, you know
like just accepting that
they were balding, you know
you do go through that five stages.
- First few, I think year
or two where it's happening.
You're like, no, I can,
I could reverse this.
I can, I can reverse this.
- The five stages of balding group.
I think you do, right?
- The five stages of acceptance.
First is like, what's
the word am looking for?
- Denial.
First you like no,no,no
- And I'm sure this conversation
where he hits quite close
to home to a lot of our
viewers because all audiences
mainly dudes.
Yeah. If it is happening to
you, don't give a fuck, man.
Just whatever.
just whatever.
- I mean, you can do whatever you want.
- Its not like society
fucking rejects you.
- Because you are bald.
- I, you know, I feel like,
you know, some people are
you know, I, I, for one, I
have been bald before and I,
I do, I do want it man.
But I do like my hair and
you know, I am putting
in steps to
you know, I, I don't
expect to this forever, but
I would like to elongate
it for as long as I can.
You know, I'm still, I'm,
self-aware enough to know that
you know, once it's
past the point it's gone
but at least right now,
when I still have this hair
I'm gonna be like, okay, you know
I'm gonna lose this
eventually, but I am gonna try
and do my best at this
point to just keep it.
And I don't think there's
anything particularly
wrong about it.
There's no, there's
nothing particularly wrong
with either direction that you go to.
I think it's more just, you
know, I, some, some people, I
you know, I like the
feeling of having hair.
I like the feeling.
I like the feeling of, you
know washing your hair.
And my God.
Especially fucking one
thing that nobody tells you
about being bald, right?
- It's getting old, right.
- It's fucking cold.
- Okay. You're either cold.
Or if you're in a hot humid country
like Thailand, mosquitoes,
it's free real estate.
There's an extra surface
area for the mosquitoes.
Just go fucking mental.
- I do it just like a park.
Its like, oh shit!
- I won't lie, I do you like the idea
of being able to optimize
my bathing experience,
which is like,
- Your bathing time is like cut by half.
- Am like, when you get out,
bro you're immediately dry.
That sounds amazing.
You know how, like in a hurry, I am.
- Single wipe.
- Yeah.
- And also like ,do you use the,
I mean, shampoo is irrelevant, right?
- Yeah yeah. Shampoo is irrelevant.
- You save so much money.
- Dude what the fuck?
- You know I hate like
organic fucking shampoo
that isn't like full of
like sulfates assumptions.
Cap it.
I mean
Yeah. As well, I did have this thought.
I was like, you know what?
It's like, I don't know
if this is creepy or what to some people
but I think it's kind of cool that like,
my whole adult life is like
captured in like YouTube.
Like you can see like my
whole, like, there'll be like,
- You can see the progress.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, like 19 year
old me that's like spots
and like fucking pepperoni face.
And then in like 10
years, you'll see me like,
- Its the glow.
- Actually, I think, I think
it's kind of like, I dunno.
I think it's kind of fascinating
that I can have like a,
you know as cringy as it might be.
I can have like a backlog that I can
- Cause what I, what I
find interesting right.
Is, you know, I don't know what
it was like for your parents
but my parents were like
pretty old right now.
So there's not too many photos
of when they were younger
and like my age especially.
So, you know, I'd see
photos here and there
and you're just like,
damn! That's what you
looks like, like, okay.
But for you, you know, when we have kids
we have like our entire
life just like documented
but that's, that's true
for most people, like, even
above like being YouTube
was you got Facebook photos
going back to like, my,
my kid will definitely
know my entire life up to like university.
I'm like, there are some uni
photos where I'm just like,
damn son or daughter.
I don't know if I wanna go through this.
- I don't know if it's
a good or bad thing.
I lost a lot of my photos
pre 18, like on Facebook.
I post most of them.
- Yeah.
- Because I hated how I looked in them.
So I was like fuck it.
I mean, no one likes having those.
- Yeah, but, and I thought,
should I keep them?
And I was like, no, I'm
getting rid of them.
So I actually, I've lost a lot of them.
I pretty much have, like, I
would say an average amount
of like that anyone would
have someone who took photos.
Right? Yeah.
But I think it's cool as an adult
I can make the choice to be
like, I'm fine with having most
of my like adult life
essentially be documented.
I think that's kind of cool.
I mean, whether my future kids think so.
- Yeah He's like,
- That's up to them.
- I'm I'm sorry for
any future kid who goes
through my Twitter timeline,
God, I'm so fucking sorry.
- Am sure Twitter at some point,
we'll do like a big purge of life.
- You think so? I don't think so.
- How can you store all that shit?
- The sponsor of today's
episode is EJAimestore.
- What is EJ stand for Garnt?
- I've never said this before
but EJAnime store stands
for Entertainment Japan.
- Whoa! I didn't know that.
- And if you don't know
what EJAnime store is,
it is cut ACOs official
online anime merch store
that specializes in delivering the newest
and most exclusive official anime merch
to overseas fans directly from Japan
such as these that are
on the table right now.
Look at them.
What do we got today Connor?
- Wow.
I'm glad you asked Garnt.
We have the Connor super
mega minion Yunyun.
What's the hell is a Yunyun?
- That's a Yunyun.
(Garnt laughs loudly)
- The mega man and Yunyun light novel
Chinese style dress versions inspired
by a set of illustrations
created specifically
by the corner, super
light, novel illustrator
crony Mishima to celebrate
union's character birthday
the Calico, a special set
each include a rubber desk mat
for illustrations that
inspired these figures
as an exclusive bonus.
- I love Connor super Garnt
but what else do we have?
- Well, for the cultured
individuals out there .
- That's me.
- We have the redo of healer, Freya
and such lighter novel versions.
- I can't actually believe
that they may figure it out.
- I'm surprised.
I'm actually shocked that
they've made figurines of this
and they good.
- EJAnime still brings
you the two main heroines
of the show that has gotten a
lot of attention this season.
- Yeah, definitely has gotten a lot
of attention this season.
Let's be sure, let's be real.
Enjoy these cultural
representations of Freya
and Setsuna that included
additional exchangeable face parts
and were inspired by a set
of new original illustrations created
by the original light novel
illustrator shell combo.
The category special sets
each includes a fabric poster
of the illustrations that
inspired these figures
as an exclusive bonus
- Guys but we can't forget the
bang dream girl band party.
Roselia Yukina Minato Pajama version.
- Go check out all of these
items on EJANIMESTORE.COM
while they're still available
or click the link in the description.
And if you haven't already follow them
on Facebook and Twitter @ejanimestore.
So you don't miss any of their giveaways
and limited time offers.
- Thank you, EJAnime store
for sponsoring this episode.
Back to the show.
- Yeah, I think they can because I mean
that just means like
that YouTube, you know
all the YouTube videos in the
world have a finite shelf life
and basically every media
and every big website
in the world has a
finite shelf life. Right?
Yeah. Surely. So I dunno.
I like,
like you said,
when it comes to online media,
I kind of act like a hoarder right?
(chuckles)
Like I don't know what I can look back.
Yeah, exactly.
I don't know what I could
look back in, in a few years
and be like, yeah, I tweeted
that back in 2008 or two.
I couldn't remember when
I started my Twitter, man.
It's been, it's been a while.
- Didn't even know that
Twitter was that old honestly.
Yeah. Because I have,
I have this thing on, I
don't know if you have it.
I think you do right where,
like I have this thing
on my Twitter where like,
if the tweet is older
than two months, then
it automatically delete.
- I think that might
set like two years just
cause like every time I look back
at myself two years, I'm
like, fuck I was crunchy.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I'm like that six months ago.
So I'm just like...
- I didn't look.
I like the ability to look back
and be like, man, I was fucking cringy.
I like the ability to
look back and go, man
what the fuck was, this was
this anime zone hairstyle?
What the fuck man.
- I got that on YouTube.
- That's what YouTube channel is for.
- For Twitch clips, you
know, all that shit.
That's what that's for you.
- I already have like one website to like
remind me of how cringey I used to be.
I want like multiple
websites to remind me how
cringey I used to be.
- I wanna know what
cringey thoughts I had.
So, you know, that's,
that's not just pictures.
I want everything.
I don't wanna go back to like
my personal Facebook and
big go back to like 2010
and being like, Oh God,
why the fuck did I tweet
shit out like that?
Or message shit out like that.
- No, cause going back
to the bald conversation.
Yeah. And like rock rocking
and style and everything like that.
So I remember I had to, I had to go
through this exact process
when I finished being a monk
and I was just, I was just bald, right?
- And we talked about
before, how, you know
you can't, you can't really,
it's hard to rock a bald style
when you don't have a beard or anything.
I feel like it's especially
hard as an Asian as well.
So like initially all I
did was just like wear,
like wear a beanie.
And the thing, the thing about
this like frail Asian kid
wearing a beanie walking, right.
You look like a cancer patient.
Like that's, that's, you know, that's,
that's, that's kind of
like what I look like
On the outside.
So I was like, I'm tired Of this.
You know, I want at least change my style.
- Right.
- So I was thinking, well,
what can I possibly do?
And the only other style I
can think of is like, what
what do you think of when you think,
you know, bald head shaved?
- You think you kinda, you kinda think
of like somebody who just
like a delinquent, right?
- Someone's like a skinhead.
- You like, it's like a skinhead, right?
So I tried to go for that look
and I have a picture actually.
I dug this up during the break.
Let me see if I can get it.
But yeah, I went for, I
went for the skinhead look.
And for the first, for the
first and only time in my life.
I looked like a complete,
- Whoa!
- I look like I just came out of prison.
- You look like Asian Jason Statham.
(laughing loudly)
- That's fucking awesome.
- I kinda love that.
- Yeah.
- That's dope. That was dope as fuck.
- If I saw someone walking the streets.
- Its Garnt.
- I have never felt like it.
It's the glasses and the scarf.
- Okay. This is the first
and only time in my life
where I felt dangerous.
- Right. I would, I would be
like, I'll be walking down
- Move away from me.
- Because I was living in
China at this time, right?
And so I would be walking down the streets
and sometimes if it,
if it was it was dark,
I could see like groups of girls
or groups of anyone just
like subtly cross the road.
Whenever I was, I was okay.
And this, this one time.
So I was with some friends there
and it took me like to this local bar
who's run by this like
frail, you know, you know
one of the old Asian ladies
who run this local bar.
And so we walk in and
she dead ass looks at me
and I could see her have like a mini
a mini fucking heart attack.
She's like, "What?"
And then she goes to my mate
and goes, "I'm sorry,
we're closed right now."
And my mates, like, no, I
I've been here quite often.
I, you know, I know this
place is open as she did.
I says to him, I'm just not
looking for trouble right now.
- Garnt is the kind of
guy who you would say
am not looking for trouble.
- I mean look, I don't blame you, man.
Like if I, if I was that frail old lady
I feel like I would
I would look at that and be
like, Oh, that's Chinese mafia.
- Were you wearing the sunglasses?
And the scarf as well?
- I was wearing the scarf.
- Yeah. That's Chinese mafia dude.
Am not dealing with that shit.
- Yeah. The scarf says like, it's Louie,
but I mean, you know, I
kill as well you know.
- The scarf says I'm hiding tasks.
That's what that say.
You don't wanna see the
tasks I have underneath.
- Yeah. Looking like this
it felt like you know,
that meme with that guy
in the party being like
they don't know him a fair load on me.
- I don't know.
I kill people.
(laughing loudly)
- It's like the big coat as well.
It's like, yeah, I might
be concealing a weapon
but I'll never say.
- This is honestly the first time
I ever like tried wearing a leather jacket
and I'm just like,
"Tom, you know what?"
- Actually you look
good in leather jacket.
- I love leather jacket.
- Is that why you wear leather
jackets a lot nowadays.
- Ever since this is where it started.
- Actually looks good on you.
- The only one I know where it's like,
damn, he fucking kills a leather jacket.
up who will like, Oh, you know, I want to
I want to get back into
like the whole like eighties
like street wear spirit and you know
the punk spirit and like
wear a leather jacket.
And it just, it looks so lame.
- Some people do look
like they're just wearing
the dad's clothes.
Jackets.
- Yeah. I tried to once
and I was like, nah,
it's not for me.
- Yeah. For me, the one piece
of clothing I find really
hard to rock is a good suit.
I dunno.
I dunno what it is about a suit, right?
- I love wearing suits.
I know you love wearing.
You use every opportunity
you can to just rock
up when you were jojo suit.
- Going to the grocery store, suit up
- Suit up.
- Why not?
Suits is so fun to wear, man.
It is really fun.
- You feel like you commend a presence
when you're wearing your suit.
You know, like when I,
when I leave my house
around the Jojo suit, like, like, you know
like I go on the train, I'm
like, yeah, I'm wearing it.
- Cause like, for me, I
like, I can rock a suit
but it really needs to be tailor-made.
Cause like anything else,
if most like my entire life
if I just buy like this
stormy too, you know, it feels
it just feels like, and
where my dad's clothes, I
I look like five years younger
and I, and that's not a good
it's not a good five years
younger than it looks I'm back
to being a teenager or
something like that.
- Yeah. I don't know.
Especially as well here,
if you were anything other
than the standard businessman
suit here, which is like
what? The Navy
- Like the Navy blue,
white t-shirt on today.
- It's like nobody made
it, it's like dark Navy.
Like they all wear the same goddamn suit.
So when I, you know, when
I whip out my little light
burgundy, what color is it like beige?
The Jojo beige suit.
Stands out so fucking much.
Am like, yeah bitch!
- Like I forget.
Sometimes you have, you
bought two jojo suits
because you only wear that one.
- Yeah, cause the other one,
it's like way more formal.
So it's a little harder to wear it.
Like on just kind of like
not super serious things.
- Yeah have got the other one, the,
the butcher ADI one, the Navy blue
like kind of double standard.
- It's also like a crossover.
And I feel like the crossover is
like more mafia or like super serious.
Whereas the German one, cause
it's just like super chill.
It's like Bay, beige
is not a serious color.
No people who wear beige
don't do serious things
but you look good, look good
- Explain serious thing.
- Like you see someone wearing this suit.
- Like people, mafia men can wear beige.
- Here's the Giordano suit.
Here's the Bruichladdich suit, right?
The Butchuaratty suit looks
like you've you are killing people.
You're trading
in stocks that can't be
bought by public citizens.
You know, the journal one
looks like, you know, like
like you have fun times.
You go out for nice meals,
you know, it's, you know
it's a different kind of atmosphere.
- I go to the gold bar every now
and then it's a different kind
of atmosphere that it gives off.
- Right.
- It's like wearing a three piece.
You can't just casually
wear a three piece.
- You look so good in the three-piece
because I did something, you
know, I like how men's fashion
no matter how, how much time has passed.
Right. A suit and a three-piece
just always looks good.
It's just something that is timeless.
And I don't know what it is.
They've just like, we, we
optimize how good guys could look
like hundreds of years ago.
And then it just hasn't
changed since then.
- Yeah. The standard has
always been the same.
- I don't really spend
much money on clothes
but obviously suits quite expensive.
And then you only bought, bought a suit
Will know that.
- Like a nice suit.
Yeah. Like a nice suit right?
Like, yeah.
You can go to prime Mark and
get the $20 here or whatever.
And it doesn't look bad.
Actually. It doesn't.
I remember I was telling,
like I was talking about on
on Twitch, I was talking
about the Jojo suits
I'm bringing out new Jojo suits.
And I was like, yeah, I'm
going to buy them all.
And they were like,
Powerful ones right?
Yeah. And then like the
like 500 bucks each.
And I'm like, listen guys for a suit
500 bucks is not that much.
Especially if you can go in there and get
they tailored a little bit
to you like this, come on.
Come on, these suits are fucking gold
- Especially as an adult as well.
Like that's just gonna to last.
- Yeah bro.
You think I'm only ever wearing
those job Jojo suits now
- Like one time thing
- Never wearing.
I'm never wearing any other suits ever.
I'm in a pretty well, but I mean
I'm gonna get my money's worth, right?
And also the nice things
that luxurious man
you gotta like, you know, a good suit.
You can't cheap out.
If you go to a job interview
wearing a cheap-ass suit
come on, come on.
I mean,
- You go to a job interview
wearing Jojo suit?
- Bro they're like,
- Instant application.
- Presents has been commended you know.
You walk in right.
- This boy is serious and he's beige.
- Nevermind. He's got a Jojo suit.
- He's got a beige suit on he's.
He's good.
- I mean that's the thing about the suit,
is that it's one of, it's one
of the few things that you
really can't cheap out on them.
You can try it.
I mean like, you know, you can go
to places like get a pretty cheap suit
in somewhere like Thailand.
That's like tailor made
and everything like that.
But if you don't have
that luxury of buying
of going to a place where
it can be made for cheap
then a cheap suit really
shows like most like no
- When you wear it as
well, what's a good suit.
You feel like damn, I'm powerful.
It comes off in the
aura that you give off.
It's like some Hunter,
Hunter, Nan stuff, right?
People feel your presence.
When you, when you're in a good suit
people know you are in a good suit.
They feel it
in the way I'm telling you,
man, it's not bullshit.
That's what, that's what I do.
- When I go buy a suit,
I'm just like, excuse me.
It's the aura tailor.
- Honestly. It's an option though.
- You know it's to tailor-made
when they're asking questions
you're like, what the
fuck you talking about?
They're like, they're asking you stuff.
Like, how would you like this or that?
And I'm like
I've never been asked
that question in my life.
What is that?
Doesn't they show you like, I don't care.
What do you think?
You're the tailor you tell me?
It's like
- Would you like two centimeters
or three centimeters off your coffee?
I don't know.
- Yeah. Like when they ask like
do you want the leg rolled up
at the bottom of the steps?
And I'm like, I don't know.
- She didn't tell me what looks good.
I literally have no, what do you tell me?
- Cause I remember like the
first time I wore a suit was
for like my high school
prom or something like that.
- I think that was the first
time for like everybody.
- That's when you get
like the prime marks.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I'm going to find you a good suit.
Cause you're not gonna get me any value
out of that little shit.
- Yeah.
And everyone, everyone does look like
they're wearing their dads suit.
(laughing)
I think it's possible.
- Its like lets go dads.
(laughing)
- Its like the oversized suits.
Oh God.
- It looks so unnatural.
- The good old days where just...
(chuckles)
- Why is it that every like 16 year old
who goes to like the first
prom in a suit just looks like,
they're just like,
- Cause you not comfortable in it.
- Yeah. But like, it's, it's so funny.
How like every photo of ever
seen either off myself or
of my friends, or just
complete random strangers
out their proms,
they all look like the T-posing.
You know what I mean?
(laughing)
they are like, they all like
there's a standing like,
yes, we are at a prom.
(laughing)
- A suit it's like 50% the suit,
50% how comfortable
you feel wearing these.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Can you embody what a suit is?
You know, you can't just
put on a suit and be like,
I guess I'm, I guess I'm
kinda like attractive now.
No. You've got to believe that
when you put that suit on,
- Yeah.
- I'm hot.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You got to give off that aura.
You got to have faith.
- But like, okay, there's
always, this there's always like
every time I wear a suit, right.
There's always this countdown of like
when am I going to take this jacket off?
Cause inevitably when you
go to like any celebrations
or something, you're gonna
get too hot on that side.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- Of course.
- And I feel like, you know,
if you're gonna take pictures
or do anything get it right at
the beginning of the nights.
- Yeah.
- Because there's nothing more messy
than like just the suit that, you know
has just been battered and damage.
And like you can tell
it's not the suit itself.
It's the tie, right?
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah.
- Its like at the beginning
you're like, you got
your buttoned up right to the top button.
(Joey gasping for air)
Your tie is tight.
You look fucking suave.
- [Conner] Yeah.
- Five hours in,
God, you're a sweaty mess.
That Tie has taken a beating.
It's like, it's like
halfway down your chest.
- Yeah.
(Joey laughs)
- One thing, Japan is like
advanced technology and is like
that business shirts are like next level.
- Yeah.
- Like I've, I don't
know how they've done it.
But Japan is like, optimize
the fuck out of like, shirts.
- Yeah.
- Like business shirt.
- Of course they have.
Cause everyone,
- Everyone's wearing.
- Everyone wearing.
- Every person here is a salary man.
- Yeah. I mean, I put
this thing on at first,
and it was a little pricey.
I thought, you know, I
mean, I guess, you know,
from buying a nice suit,
I buy a nice shirt.
- Even. I it's always an after thought
cause I always think if
it's wide, who gives a fuck?
Then I put this thing on,
and I'm like, Whoa, it
breathes, is stretches
It looks clean.
It washes super-easy.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And I'm like, Whoa, I've
never like appreciated a shirt
until Japan.
- I remember, I remember I saw
an ad, for like last summer.
- Yeah.
- When it was like, you
know that fucking heat wave.
- It doesn't matter if
it's like 40 degrees
or it's four degrees.
People are wearing a suit.
- The materials feels amazing.
- But I remember I saw an ad,
which dead are said, like this
this business shoulder has
self cooling technology.
(Garnt laughing loudly)
- I get it
- Cooling technology.
Like it's a, it's a piece of cotton.
- Some of them like
have like a stretchiness
to it that makes it like,
feel really like air rated.
I don't know what it is.
Okay. If you come to Japan, right.
And you like your, your shirts.
Yeah. Dead ass, you know,
bringing my animate figures
get some Japanese shirts
go to like perfect suit factory here.
And just go and put, get
go and get some biceps, self cooling.
They legit.
They good.
I feel like whenever Japan
- Like advertisers as
new fancy technology is
though it's it's it's hit or miss
because sometimes you get good things
like the heat tech here
the Heat tech when you go
to Uniqlo and it's winter,
those are fucking great.
- The cool shirts, yeah.
- The cool shirts are obviously great.
I remember though
recently, like Uniqlo also
released the, they,
you know, this was deep
during the pandemic.
It was debriefing during
quarantine and they released
like their own Arizona masks
or something like that.
That was meant, that was
meant to like be more
breathable fabric or something like that.
And, and it, it got so
high that it's sold out
on the first day immediately,
people were queuing
up to buy these masks.
And I think about three months
into it, I was at Uniqlo
and miraculously.
They were just back on sale day.
They just come back into stock.
So I was like, you know what,
I'm gonna give this a try
because this has been sold out.
And I'm tired of my, you
know, of like of my masks.
So let's, let's, let's see
how breathable this is.
And it literally, it literally
felt like you'd just worn
like, you know, one of
those like anime knickers.
Anime masks.
- Just like underwear.
- It literally just felt like
you had underwear in your face.
And it was a fucking lie.
This thing was this thing, this thing felt
like he was going to give me asthma.
It was not breathable at all.
- We have a lot of fats they're here
and his fat fad technology wasn't there
- Like the, a necklace or
something was meant to prevent.
- Literally I see some people
wearing it's called virus out.
Like literally just like a
necklace and everyone's wearing.
- Yeah. Hockey made like an
entire video about like a bunch
of like Corona virus, scam items.
And one of them was that it's like, it's
like this fucking lucky charm
looking thing where it's like,
"Go away virus."
It was literally that energy.
- It's just like, it's just
it's just a car air
freshener around your neck.
- I'd rather you not care
than have that and be like I care.
Yeah. Cause, cause like at least
you not pretending at that point.
- Yeah.
- The fact that they're like
I saw a bunch of people who like, like
especially like older, like
women, you know, always believe
in that for some reason
who would like wear that
and be like, Oh, I don't
have to wear a mask anymore.
I'm I'm fully protected with this.
You know?
- I mean, it's the same
reason anti-vaccine
and stuff like exists. Right?
Because this kind of, you know, if
if you have a small, small
enough group who trade in
like trade information
within that group, then
they're just gonna stop
leaving the wall to sometimes.
And you know, it's a lot
of like the image globally is
that a lot of people, a lot
of this is confined to America,
but you know, it's all over.
It's all over the world.
Like it is all over the place
as stupidity is not confined by one type
of like nationality or just
the big difference is like
it seems in America,
it's just more documented
and its more widespread.
- That's unfortunate.
Cause like, I mean like, like you said
like the stupid, I do agree.
They are stupid, but it's
been like proven, right?
If you keep calling them stupid
it like makes them believe in it more.
Yeah. You're like, you're
like, you're a conspiracy.
You're like
- Are you working with the government?
You're one of them.
But also at the same time
- I don't wanna sit there
and humor stupid ideas.
- Yeah. So it's like, yeah, I don't know.
I don't, I don't really talk about it.
I don't really get involved with it.
Cause I'm just like, I feel
like it's a lose, lose.
These people should know about.
Yeah. You know, I just like
to think that, you know, like
for example, if my mum one day
got into something like that
that I'd like to be able to think
that I could maybe talk her out of it.
Like mom. Come on.
Yeah. Yeah.
The PG tips is not poisoned.
- You can drink the tea mom.
(joy laughs)
I'm pretty sure we'd all be dead.
You know, just give me a fake.
It's unfortunate.
- Wasn't it like the England in England?
What? Like the 5G towers caused.
- That was embarrassing or whatever.
Whatever it was, yeah.
- That was like huge in the UK.
The people would like
burning down these towers.
It's embarrassing.
You like, these are like
I live in the same
country with these people.
I went to the same schools as these people
who burned down fucking 5G towers.
- So that fact of like,
you know, you should
you shouldn't like when,
when footwear wireless
like Bluetooth headphones
first came out for your phone
be like, people should
use those because if you
if you're on the phone like
this, then the signal actually
- I remember that.
Yeah. I remember that.
And there were people,
at least in Australia,
like when I was growing up, there were
like, people dead ass being like,
"shit, I have to go buy
some Bluetooth headphones.
You know, I don't wanna
get a tumor in my brain
from all these phone calls I'm taking."
I'm like, "what are you on?"
- I think one of the most
interesting things I've like,
I've seen happen recently
that's happened right in front of my eyes
is the fucking toilet paper shortage.
Right?
Like, like I think back to that and like,
- Why does that feel like 10 years ago?
- I know.
I think back to that,
unlike our kids are gonna
be reading about this or
like, they're gonna see like
isn't it, they're going to see
the Israeli historian video
like 20 years in the
future and, and be thinking
like my generation, whenever
this stupid, it's like
I'm just imagining like,
you know, 20 years from now
like our kids, right.
Will be like in fucking history class
like modern history being like class.
All right so class today
we're gonna be talking about
the 2020 great toilet paper shortage.
Like it's the same as the crank depression
- Blew my mind.
How in Japan, it happened as well.
I'm like, we literally have, yeah.
- It blew my mind.
What do you guys clean your ass with?
That happened worldwide.
It was literally like a
idea that spread worldwide.
Even though like nobody,
nobody knew where it came from.
It's the family in Australia.
Not proud of it
but like, like the thing
is nobody like another
countries really knew that
it came from Australia
cause they were just
like, Oh, toilet paper.
I must buy.
I don't know why, but everyone
else is buying toilet people.
Therefore I must buy a toilet paper.
- It didn't occur to people
that maybe like, you know
if everyone just keeps using toilet paper
at the same rate that we've all been using
it it'll continue to be the same.
Right.
- Cause I don't know why.
Cause he was out of every
household necessity that you
think would happen that
you think people would
need an apocalypse food, water, I sleep.
Toilet paper. I wake.
This is the real shit.
- So what do people think that like
if you got COVID you also
got irritable bowel syndrome.
I'm like ,
- In my mind as well, I'm like
do I really want to be an who just goes
and like takes everything in the shop.
I'm like, I mean, I'll
take like a little bit
of like pasta a little bit
of canned goods, like enough.
- Yeah. Like we, like, we
stepped up, but we didn't
like be like, can I have
everything on that shelf
from there to there?
No, we, we, we, we only stocked
up just because there was
a literal shortage and there
was a literal point where
I had trouble wiping my
ass because there wasn't,
there was no toilet paper.
- The day gang rise up.
- I was gonna clean my
ass by the end of the day,
but I wasn't gonna step out with a wet ass
like fuck that shit.
- I just jiggle a little shake
because it was the one piece of like
everyday household equipment.
They, you know, you can
understand so, you know?
Okay. I understand if there
would be a shorter dish soap
I can understand hand sanitizer.
Of course.
I understand why there
would be food and water
- Food and water.
There wasn't any
- I'm like, do you know
how easy it is to live
off like rice or pasta?
Like you don't need much of that.
- But there was even a
shortage of like pasta as well.
Like I remember.
Yeah. I remember, I remember
the video of, I think it was
in Italy that there was like
all of those supermarkets
and the old guy was
like getting pissed off
cause there was no pasta
in the supermarket.
And he was like," people
weren't this obsessed during
world war two.
We had more pasta in world war two
than we do now, what
the fuck is going on?"
- I guess the problem is is that
like everyone's telling each other yeah.
You should panic.
Like in real time.
Right? Spread it out.
It's like, Oh my God.
I don't know.
I had a bunch of cop ramen
and I was like, I'm pretty.
I think I'm good.
I'll see what happens.
Like I'm pretty sure the
stores aren't just gonna shut.
- I like there would
be an exact point where
I would like start panicking.
And that exact point is
if I found out the company was closed.
Cause like, I, I feel like,
Hey, if the company closes
you're going through some real shit.
- That is when I truly woke.
Are we really going through an apocalypse.
Okay. I wake now. Am fucked.
- Like America, that like waffle house.
And like you can judge on
like the disaster based
on where the wasp waffle
house is open or closed.
It's like, it's an actual
like study like thing where
like, even when there's
like hurricanes waffle house
in America is still open.
- Wow. Seriously?
Yes. You should look it up.
- Its really interesting.
- I like, I think, I don't know.
We didn't know which of big
natural disaster it was.
I think it must have
Katrina or something else.
It was still open.
- Cause they're all
equipment like generators.
Right? Why?
In case of disaster
- The like one of the
only things that like will
try their best to stay open.
Unless like, you know
the disaster is so bad when
waffle house in America...
- It's like damn, my
roof just got blown off
could kill for some waffles.
- Like windows and shit are broken.
I think they'd still continue to be open.
Like I'll let you in.
I I'm not, I'm not sure exactly.
It could be checking out my ass
but this is as far as been there.
- Yeah. Cause I
I think what's this entire
situation has made me
realize is I remember like, Oh,
before, before 2020 watching
like old school zombie movies
and something like that.
And you'd think to
yourself, man, they made the
they made the people really
stupid in this zombie movie.
This would never happen in real life.
And now I look back and I'm like,
- Oh its definitely gonna happen.
- I'm like they didn't
make them stupid enough.
Jesus Christ.
- People that like rounds
up people and feeds them
to the zombies because
they think it'll probably
appease the zombie or something.
Some shit like that.
- Yeah. I look at something
like dead rising and I'm like,
well this is unrealistic.
There's still things inside
all of the stores to pay for.
It's still what the there?
Isn't a subgroup
of people praising the
zombie what's going on.
- I, I am curious for every
like zombie story and like every
like every kind of like apocalyptic story
like would like how
if 2020 would have changed,
like how cliches and tropes
- You get a million boring movies
about this current pandemic.
And
- Can you make an exciting
movie about the pandemic?
I mean, they tried to do with 2012.
Right. They made one like
in 2006 or seven were like
- Oh it was pandemic.
Right. That was
- Pandemic. There's like a few movies.
They're like, they're
like worryingly close
to like what happened?
- Yeah. That was the, that
was the one that went viral.
I think I saw it last year.
Whereas I was like crazy.
Like
- In the movie there was like a pandemic.
That was like completely
obviously named something
completely differently
than the years before.
And, and I think it'd go
viral because people found it
on Netflix and started watching it.
And the dead, the plot is that there was
a virus that was started
in China through bats.
Really?
Yeah. And people like
- Some chef had it and they
shook hands with a businesswoman
- And then spread to America.
Like half of America died.
I think it was mad thing.
- Fucking mad thing.
I love you right here.
- People are like, Oh my God,
this is almost scarily similar
to what's actually happening right now.
- Probably smarter because
people probably acted much
a lot smarter in that movie.
- No, no, no, no.
- In that movie as well
they were just like instantly
die for some reason.
Matt Damon and his kid I think.
- Were immune.
- Were immune,
because of course Matt Damon.
I'm pretty sure if that happened.
Matt Damon and Tom cruise be
fucking immune to anything.
- Yeah. Matt, Matt Dame.
I think Matt, the, in the movie
Matt Damon was like, I
quarantine, nevermind.
I'm immune now.
(laughing loudly)
He laid like dead.
I stayed inside of a room for two weeks.
And then the doctor was like
guess you're immune now
was a pretty good movie.
If you've watched it.
- I've just seen clips of it online
- Contagion. That's pretty good.
It's pretty fun watching
it now being like, yeah
that's fine.
- It must be, it must be weird watching it
during the pandemic and
seeing being like, this is a
this is uncomfortably close
to what's happening now.
- It makes you realize
how lucky we got that.
It could have been way worse.
Like it could have just
immediately killed people.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Cause I think, you know,
we, we've obviously gone
through a really harsh
period right now, but I feel
like humanity really just got
like, we got the best warning.
So this was, this was
the best warning sign
that we could have gotten.
And I say this, obviously
knowing that, you know, it's
it's a tragedy
how many people have died, but
get the, the scary thing is
that it could have been
so much worse than it was.
And this was, this was kind of
like the worst case scenario
for how easily transmittable
this virus could have been.
But in terms of like, in terms
of like its actual effect
it could have been a lot worse.
And I say this
with the awful results
we've gotten so far.
- And it's just, it's just
scary to think that, you know
if this had happened, you know, 50,
a hundred years prior, how much?
Probably much, much, much
worse it could have been.
You know
- It's weird because
like, I I've been thinking
about this a lot because it's, it's been
like a full year now, since,
since I remember thinking, Oh
this is gonna, this is
gonna last a few months.
Yeah.
- There's this quarantine thing, right?
This is a, this is a little,
this is a, I came together.
It's like, woo, woo bunk
up for like two months.
And then, you know
we'll be able to go outside
and enjoy the summer.
- The joke was like, Oh, anime nuts
ha I've found I was born for this.
And then I kind of realized pretty soon
that there's a big difference
between choosing to stay home
and being forced to stay home.
I don't know what it is
but there's a big fucking difference.
- I saw a tweet that was like, man
are people going to judge people
who have a time readapting
to social situations.
- Right.
And I was like, "what?
What do you mean?
- What do you mean readapting ?
- Like people who have been like
living in the house for too long alone
they were like, I hope
we don't get judged.
- What they're suddenly gonna
go outside and being like
how do I interact with you?
I thought it was a little odd.
What do you think they were like?
- [Meilyne] I agree.
- You agree?
- You agree Meilyne?
- [Meilyne] I'm worried.
- You're worried
- You're worried.
(laughing loudly)
- Why?
You're the fucking socialite.
- [Meilyne] With you...
(laughing loudly)
- You guys aint people.
I've been in the joint for too long man.
I do not have to re acclimate to society.
- Just like, you know when you
see shit like that on Twitter
It was just read something
like it was like, they made it out.
Like it was way more serious
and like a big issue than it was.
And I'm like, bro, it's
literally talking to people.
Yeah.
- What do you, what do you
how is this not second nature to you?
- You know, struggled to
socialize, but acting as
if like your life has just
been flipped upside down
and it's going to take so much readjusting
like you'd like to get over this.
I'm like, bro
- It's not like you're
trying to learn a language
that you stopped learning after work.
- Maybe shouldn't take, I don't know.
It could be a shitty take.
I, I was just like, what am I done?
- Well, you're obviously not part of that.
Right. There's a hashtag rolling
- I know am quite extroverted.
And I obviously can't sympathize
100% with introvert problems.
He, he XD hashtag.
But like, you know, I
mean, to me, I was like
it kind of seemed like they
were trying to make it.
Like, I don't know.
Cause sometimes Twitter
does this where it's like
guys, guys, I have a problem, guys.
I need to tell you about my problem guys.
Please come on.
- I, I believe that I
believe that's called first
world problems where
it's like, the woe is me.
- Well, I don't know.
Like I can,
I can kind of understand.
But at the same time
how is it gonna be diff
like how are you gonna
how is that much different
from what you were like before?
Like what's normal.
That's what I mean.
It's like, no
one's going to force you to
go outside after the pandemic.
If anything, people are
probably about just go back
to being, we'll just go
back to the situation
with people who are
choosing to be inside rather
than taking a flight, going on a plane.
- Its like, If you will,
if you loved being inside
before the pandemic
you're probably still going to be
inside after the pandemic.
Let's be real.
No, it's like the police
aren't gonna come and be like
all right, you've been in
this room for too long.
All right. Get the fuck out.
You gotta, you gotta
- He's missed your mouth.
It's been there.
- I don't know.
Do you think there are
going to be any big changes
once this pandemic safe?
Or are we just going to be like, huh?
That was a funny thing that
happened last year, right?
I mean like in terms of
Japan, like, you know
because we're already such a
bomb, Japan, we're going to
stop wearing masks.
Now. Why?
Because before, you know,
it was still a socially
accepted norm for people
to wear masks, but not
everyone wore masks.
And now I feel like now it's
going to be so deeply ingrained
in the culture that I feel like 90 to 80%
of people are just going
to be permanently masks.
- Oh yeah, of course.
I mean, you know, like
people already wear masks
see you like, you know, during
especially this time of
year where like, you know
hay fever because you
know that kind of stuff.
And then, you know
you have like the influenza season in like
November where people are
getting sick all the time
everyone's wearing a mask and it's like
is your face a little
bit cold, wear a mask?
- Do you know what I'm hoping?
And I think it's gonna
happen and I'm happy for it.
People are gonna take care of the hygiene
during conventions.
That's good.
(laughing)
- That's a total order.
I am hopeful that a global
pandemic will make nerds
care more about that hygiene
during a big social gathering.
I, I might, I might be
too hopeful for this.
I might be judged for this.
- I feel, you know what?
I feel if anything it's
gonna be like, listen,
we were all not gonna get each other sick.
Now. We've all, we've all gotten the shot.
And I've been, I've been forced to
use hand sanitizer and
bathe and wash my hands
for fuck far too long.
I am gonna go on a bathing strike.
- I think I'd like to just see the
like the alcohol stay in front.
- Yeah. Hand sanitizer.
I think if more people would just
especially at conventions
where you are shaking hands
with so many fucking people
and you know, you know
maybe wearing more masks
in convention does that's
not exactly a bad thing
because con flu is just an accepted part.
That is an accepted part
of every convention you
go, you go to, right?
- Well, it's more like say
here's the one thing I've never
understood about con-flu, right?
Like whenever you catch a cold, right.
It's usually from someone.
Yeah. Who's the fucker who's
going to a con with a cold?
- Because I mean, I got it, right?
Like if, if they booked it, yeah.
You've, already paid them off.
- You've already paid money.
You've booked your hotel.
Get a cough.
- But the least you can do is like,
try and stay as hygienic as possible.
- Which is why can we,
can we change this please?
- That's what am hoping.
I'm hoping that I go
to the next convention or maybe
like, not just the next one.
Cause obviously the next
one is going to be affected.
But maybe in like three years time
we still got the same
etiquette of, you know
if you know, maybe wearing
masks, isn't such a bad thing.
- Wear a mask, use hand
sanitizer, people having
hand sanitizers just like
easily readily available.
Like if I'm just like, Oh shit,
does anyone have any hand sanitizer?
And like three people
around me just be like,
yeah bro, I got your back.
I think that's the positive change.
Maybe, you know, maybe
the smell can change
but that's fascist hopeful thing.
- Can we make those ones
that like wet your hand
to oblivion illegal?
You know the ones when you
get it and it's just like
oil has been dropped on your hand.
That shit should be illegal.
- Where it's like way too sticky.
But it's like sticky.
- It's it's like, feels like
it's been hydrated to like 1000%.
Like its fucking weird.
Like why do they keep buying this shit?
Stop making them.
- That's the potent, dude.
- Is it really though?
- Yeah.
- I like the feeling of that one
cause your hands feel
clean because it's like
- 10 in a tango one time and now he wants
- Listen, don't knock
it till you try it, bro.
Fingering and tenure.
- Because like, sometimes you get like
you go to a restaurant here
and they're like, please
please sign inside your hands.
And they give you like
this, they spray it.
Like the tiniest spray
on you mentally like make
this tiny spray last, like
like cover your entire, your Palm
before you can stretch it out.
And I'm just like, you know
that picture where it's
like the door that's
being held by the Cheetos
and like the SWAT team
breaking down the door.
That's what I feel is
like, when you think of
like that piddly little spray
on you and you're like, okay
I can see this does nothing
but you're just doing it
because it's like regulations.
- Oh my hand been feel like I've just like
dunked it in like a VAT of oil.
Like that's what it feels like sometimes.
- I like the feeling
of like, like it's one
it covers your hands and
you can feel it evaporates.
So you get like a little
tingly cooling sensation.
- I rather them go overboard
with the hand sanitizer than
under board.
- Like I feel, I feel like
it's clean otherwise it is.
It's like fucking sudden..
- I know there is my hands
on the cleanest sanitize.
That's the point of hand sanitizing.
It fucking sanitizes your hand.
- That's 0. 1% of germs is clinging on
for dear life on my hands right now.
- I just prefer to use
like soap, I don't know.
I like the
- Phrase. You can't soap your hands.
- You kind of like a restaurant.
You can just be like, all right,
spray a little bit on that.
I'm gonna go to the
toilet and clean my hands.
- What?
- So much more effort.
- Yeah but I like that is
the least optimize thing.
Yeah. Coming from a man who
optimizes everything in his life
- Aren't inherently an
optimized experiences so much.
- Imagine the cue to the toilet.
If that, if that was just
norm, not everyone could be
large brained like myself, you know.
- shut up.
Just shut up.
- What you have to do is buy this gel.
It sanitize your hands.
- More like a strips your skin.
I don't know why.
You know what I mean?
- We gas up a Domus
apparently it is my weekend.
I love it when I could feel my bone.
Yeah. Cause some people know, some people
some people just have
like really sweaty hands
and it feels like, you know, that spray
that spray does nothing.
Some people need that sweater.
Your hands.
No, not my hands.
My hands are like, it's
the one that you handshake
at a con it's it's the moisture.
It's the moist.
He fell to the moist hand for some reason.
The moist hand always cold as fuck.
(laughing loudly)
It's like you feel the moistness
you're literally a cold, wet fish.
That's all it feels like.
That's what,
- it feels like grabbing like a dead fish.
Right. And going to a
supermarket and like seeing one
of those fish in the fish
section, just grabbing it.
That's what it feels like.
It is gross.
And you can never shake
that feeling off after
it's like off your hand.
- Apologies to anyone who
has cold wet hands, but
- Cold hands.
- Yeah. A sham to shaking their fish
at home and shaking their fish home.
- How can we talking
about finding Nemo and?
- Yeah. I mean, I would like to see
that from future columns,
but I mean, it's really
it's just a matter, when is the future?
- I have no interest in
going to digital conventions.
I couldn't think of a more boring thing.
- It's just sad to me.
Like they got to keep, they gotta do it.
But to me, to me, it
doesn't, it doesn't make me
feel happy that they're
doing digital dimension.
It just makes me feel sad .
- Unless I'm staying in
a scuffed hotel room,
that's fucked up from
every all everyone's shit.
Like it's just not the same.
- Yeah.
Its kinda the same as
like virtual concerts.
Like well,
that 411 was pretty cool
with like Travis Scott
did a whole thing for it though.
That's like a different experience
different experience
with like someone on zoom
just dancing in front of the
webcam being like, you know.
Hmm.
- Did you see the one that
post Malone did for Pokemon?
No. Yeah.
Post-mortem so like Pokemon
just recently announced, Oh
well pastor 25th anniversary
this year and post the Pokemon
the official Pokemon YouTube
channel did a virtual concert
with post melon and it is weird.
It is weird as fuck.
- Did Pokemon reach out to post Malone
or was that what it was like?
It was like, literally
like, think of, think
of like the Travis Scott, the
least family friendly kind
of image you could go for
that I expect from Nintendo.
It was this clip on Twitter
that went viral where
like one of the lyrics
to like post Malone song.
Like obviously, you know,
like a lot of your songs
you know, he swears and
writes, so they censored it.
But I guess they forgot to send
to this one line where he was like
it was just the sex though.
The sex though me, while this Lucia flying
in the test and learn
rapping, it was like, yeah.
So like he, they had like
the, the virtual model
of post Malone, but again,
it's like an, a Pokemon way.
Not even it's like, I don't know.
He was kind of halfway
between a Pokemon model and
just like a regular 3D model.
Okay. And it was really fucking weird
and especially weird
because like, when you think
of Pokemon and you think
of modern pop stars
post Malone is not the
first person you think.
- No. Right.
- And yet he, yeah
it was really weird just
being like at the end
of the concert, he's like,
thank you, Pokemon fans.
I love Pokemon.
- How did I not see that?
- I'm surprised you guys didn't see it
- Its like Kanye West
going on the Disney channel
like all these bitches.
(laughing loudly)
- You're such a fucking whore,
I love it.
Thank you Disney.
- Like sometimes you just
see news nowadays and like
you can't tell if it's
real when you use or just
a meme anymore.
Like the real news is the meme. Nowadays.
Sometimes like post Malone and Pokemon.
- I mean, I like post Malone,
but it was just a very strange
like, I dunno if I enjoy
the very odd comment combo
especially, especially
coming from Nintendo as well.
One of was tightening.
I mean, it was, it was good.
Like if you're a post Malone or pear fan,
then it was like cool.
I don't know about like
Pokemon fans, but I mean
I saw it was like pretty
positively received.
So I mean good on postmark
- Pokemon, AMV to post Malone's music.
I don't even know
Like it wasn't a long concert either.
It was maybe about
You know, like 15, 20 minutes.
Maybe like he played, you
know, he maybe did like three
or four songs
- So where could you watch this?
It was on Twitter.
It's on the poker.
It's on the official
Pokemon YouTube channel.
Like if you look up post
Malone, Pokemon concert,
it'll come up.
- Yeah. I just want to be in
my room, attending an event.
- There's just something about the energy
of having a crowd there
That's just that, that
you need that energy.
It's, it's something
that you can't kind of
like sadder than a virtual mosh pit.
That sounds so depressing.
Oh my God.
I'm just imagine what's
the virtual MOSFET.
It's just Twitch chat going insane.
Right? That's a virtual Marsh.
It's like, it's the same.
I love Twitch chat.
- I love interacting and I love streaming
but the second about it, when
it was supposed to be live.
Yeah. In-person when it goes to Twitch
it's just feels weird or weird.
I don't even know why
I'm like conventions.
I just think
aren't experience you inherently
just cannot experience.
- I mean, you go to
convention for the people
for the atmosphere.
Otherwise everyone would be
going on their discord servers
and talking about animating cringey.
- Right? Exactly.
You go to be cringing and
person meet other cringy people.
It was like the whole reason
why you go to like concerts.
All right.
It's like, it's it's of
course to see whoever you're
seeing live, but it's also to
fucking see it with people.
- There's something different
about seeing, you know
seeing a bland live as
opposed with other people
as opposed to seeing it, you
know, listening to the album
or seeing music videos on my that.
There's just, there's just
an energy you can't capture
if you're watching it through a screen.
And I mean, that's, that's why I get why
people have to do virtual
events and everything
but I'm kind of, I'm kind
of, I just want to attend
I miss concerts.
I miss crowds.
And I never thought I would miss crowds.
Cause like, I hate crowds
so much, but like even like
it's not just even being
there in a crowd, but just
seeing an event and just
hearing that crowd scream
there's just something special.
There's just something
that brings the hype to it.
Like I get that.
I get that like the most
recent, like the most
recent event I can think of
is a league of legends worlds.
Right. Normally I'm like
super, super hype for worlds.
Cause as you would be for
any other sporting events
but there was just something
about seeing this game
play that just didn't have
the crowd role behind it.
That just made it feel like
you were just watching a
Thailand one stream or
something like that.
- Like watching an online tournament.
Yeah. I remember the players,
they were saying as well.
They were like, yeah, it's
not the same without a crowd.
Yeah, of course you get a win.
You know, when the crowd
- When someone makes a amazing play
and you hear the roar,
there's just something special
about that.
That even though I'm not there in person.
Cause I've, I've been to,
you know, I've been there
in person and the energy
there is fucking incredible.
But even just capturing a bit
of that energy and putting
like, just hearing that
crowd scream it's it's, it's
it's something that can't be replicated.
And like I know, and I
the I think it was China
that tried adding like that
tried the cans laughter effect
where they, they, they
added fake crowds attacks.
Yeah. So what to the legal legends.
Yeah. Yeah.
I think so.
I heard like, someone's
probably going to fact check
and call me out on this,
but I think I heard that.
And that just sound...
- I wouldn't be surprised
- That sounds even
worse ,if they did that.
- Just the Friends fucking
like soundtrack starts playing.
A sound base just comes in like
(chuckles)
- Yeah. Because like, I remember like
you know, cause February
just passed and like
I love watching like the swimmer
and the Sumo season is
like during the winter.
Yeah. So just finished,
but like, of course
because it's a pandemic,
you can't have people
in the tiny, you know,
stadium watching the Summa.
So like, yeah.
It was really sad to see
this like massive Sumo
stadium only having maybe
like four people in it.
And it's just like, and you know
obviously after every wind, right.
Usually the crowd, you know
like claps or like cheers or something.
But instead it's like, someone
does this like Epic win
and like three people are clapping.
It just sounds
like a cow just feels
like the zero stakes.
- Yeah. If you can't hear anyone.
- Yeah. It was really
interesting because the swimmer
they were all wearing masks
before they got on stage.
It it's just funny seeing
them like, all right, we have
we have these precautions,
they take their masks off
they step up
and immediately just
put that faces together.
And I'm like, yes.
- Yeah. I don't know.
I don't know about this.
socially distanced.
(laughing loudly)
I don't give a shit.
Yeah. I'm just like,
you know, you pick one.
- Yeah.
- It is funny how crowds can
play into sporting event hype
because I, so I've been
recommended a lot of, like
since we did the chess
tournament, I've been
like rec been recommended
way more chess clips
and been watching my chest streamers
like Hikaru and everything like that.
And there's just like,
there's just something
about the image of had about
chess before that was boring.
And I feel a big part
of that was just how bored everyone looks
in any big chess crowds. Right?
It's like, it's like people
playing a chess till one,
during a coughing, coughing events
and whatever, whatever, what I realized.
I like one thing I've realized
about how we could like have the
the image could be easily changed
was always recommended this
other events, like clips
of this other event
where it's just a bunch
of grandmasters who went,
who are just like shooting
shooting shit and having fun.
And they weren't like
having team tournament's
and just like, and like
trash talking each other.
And I'm just like, dude, this
seems like legit fun events.
And this, this could have easily
changed the image of chess
which I think it's great.
Now that the image of chess is
being like slightly changed.
- I no, no, not everyone will
agree with you Garnt there.
- I mean, that's, that's my opinion
as a filthy casual chest player.
- GM tweeted out being like, man
it's such a shame that chess
is going in this direction.
- Yeah.
- And then everyone was just
like not serious direction
because know chess is a
lot of history behind it.
And there's a lot of people
who are like, it's, it's
you know, it's, it's big
brain, it's intelligent
and it's being watered
down for these common folk.
You know?
- I mean, you are, you
are like an ex you know
you've played chess for your country
but how do you feel about it?
- I mean, it doesn't really seem
like you had that like purist view on it.
- Cause like I hated it because
like when I was doing it,
it was a bunch of, you
know, 60 year old white men
who would just be in charge
of everything and they talked
about it.
Like, you were like the night's God.
Yeah. Culture like that.
Yeah. Cause they, you know,
it was taken very seriously
in the UK and the history
behind it is like very long
and you know, whatnot.
But you know, I don't give a fuck.
I mean, you know, if, if, if the sports
you know, wants to have more
funding and be more popular,
I think it's a good thing
people get into chess.
I mean, yeah it's a good game.
I think that it's, you know,
one of the, probably the bad
better games your kid can get into.
- Yeah. I mean, it's kind of
evolved to get with the times.
Right. And pure always.
Yeah. Yeah.
- You know, unfortunately
chess is probably
on its own, a bit boring.
Yeah. Let's be honest. Right?
Like I play it.
I could say that, but I think, you know,
adding these tournaments
that don't really take away anything
from the pro scene, you
know, if it gets yeah.
You know, if you look at
chess viewership on Twitch
you know, outside of like Polk
champs and stuff like that
the big chest dreamers
viewership has grown a lot.
- How many street, how many
viewers does he carry again?
- 25k.
- And it's, it's fucking great
because before you literally
could not make money
play like playing chess.
- So many big chest streamers now.
Yeah. And it's really Epic, Epic wine.
Its pretty epic
That like, you know,
there's room for like many chess streams
to make a living off this
and stream it and you know,
and it makes sense. Right?
Like,
- It's really taught
me how important images
in regards to like a
sports and stuff like that.
Because you have to, you know,
there's, there's, there's
you know, you've got to respect the legacy
and the history and stuff
like that, but you get
to a point where it's a
modernized, it needs to modernize.
And these catch up with the times and I've
it's great because I've gotten way more
into chess simply because
it just, it just looks fun.
It looks way more fun.
- Yeah. I mean, there's like,
like stuff like, you know
everyone thinks of sports,
like rules don't change.
Yeah. Like rules, like secret
but like stuff like basketball
I'm pretty sure that the
NBA changes the rules
have changed the rules a few times based
on what makes us more
fun viewing experiences.
Yeah. So it begs the question is
like what's more important
the sport or the audience?
Yeah. And so I think chess is
at that crossroads where
there's obviously people who
have been training their whole
life to be pros and whatnot.
And obviously, yeah, it sucks
that maybe your sport
is a little less serious
but on the other hand
you have way more opportunities,
way more money, you know
way more chance to have a
platform and do whatever you want
and be on the sidelines
being salty about it.
You're probably going to
be the one left behind.
- Yeah. It's, it's, it's a
balance at the end of the day.
Right. You can't go too
far in either direction.
- I feel, I, I feel that
like I remember when he carried got signed
up for TSM and I was just
like, Holy shit, this is cool.
This is a park.
That is a like, like just,
just like imagine, imagine
if we had a chess tournament
where people showed up
in like e-sports gowns and
e-sports shots and stuff
like that, that would be
pretty high for my opinion.
But obviously I'm a
filthy casual don't play.
I don't play chess out of
anything, but just casually.
So that's, that's just my opinion.
- I totally forgot.
I played in chess tournament.
Like last week.
I totally forgot.
I did that.
Yeah. It was fine.
I mean, I had like one hour
sleep, so it's pretty brutal.
And I had to film, like I have
to go to somebody's phone.
- I mean, you say that
but you're like, no,
knowing your schedule.
I kind of like, I was like kind of you are
you're a Dick to apex back then.
Yeah. Still kind of did it to yourself.
- Oh I did.
I just, you don't you
just say yes to something
and you're like, you don't
really think about like how
it will actually fit into your schedule.
It's just sounds cool.
- Until it happens.
- Yeah. So I got invited to
Twitch Rivals, which was like,
they wanted to do like a chess tournament
where you get padded
like a GM or something
and they tell you
which piece to move and
you have to choose which
of that piece.
If they say pawn, you
choose which of the eight
Pawns to move.
Right. And so it's pretty fun.
I mean, yeah.
I haven't played chess
since our tournament.
Yeah. So I was pretty
rusty and I'll see, not
having much sleep.
And so, yeah.
But it was good fun.
I like doing it.
It's fun.
I like playing chess, but
it's really annoying how
like there's some comments
as well that like bro Cornell
wasn't it kind of in play for?
Like when he was a kid, that's a lie.
He says now.
And I'm like, bro, if you didn't play
for like seven years and
you played now, I bet
you probably wouldn't be out of that.
- You haven't heard of a gap?
- Yeah. And also I think I'm
pretty like the same level
or pretty better as a child than I am now.
Yeah. We had to say
- I mean, it's the same logic.
It's like all you want
the quadratic equation
during school and you can't do it now.
You didn't learn it.
Yeah.
- It's also like, people
think like, you know
how good do you think that like 12
11 year olds are at this game?
I mean, there's some exceptions of amazing
- There was so many Magnus castles
right? Yeah.
- And I was like, bro, I was
like the worst on my team.
Just sneaked in.
- Like I remember when I was
talking about, you know, my
my masters and I was like, explain to you.
I couldn't remember what
equation I was talking about.
It was second order
differential equations.
I remember that now.
And I kind of says, is it
integral you're thinking of?
And I guess I was like,
yeah I guess I was thinking integer.
- I should know too as well
cause I also have it in
engineering department.
And there was so many comments like,
Garnts wouldn't have written ,
Garnt didn't pass his masters.
Couldn't even remember that.
Jesus Christ.
- If you don't use something,
surprisingly you forget it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. You'll have to understand that.
A lot of times during this podcast
a lot of us are just brain dead.
We're just, we're just chatting.
It's just like that.
- You know, it's the whole
vibe of the show where
we just talk, we don't
really plan anything.
None of the topics ever
planned beforehand, we just
we just kind of shoot the shit.
- We didn't plan to go into
the monsters topics of engineering.
- I'm sure,
If I applied for an engineering
job, I'm more qualified
than someone who is like,
hasn't got the degree
but might be studying that thing.
He probably knows more than
me at this current time.
But because I haven't done
anything for like three years.
Fuck I don't know.
- I mean, you
- Forget, you forget
it, forgot everything.
- I finally understand it at the time
but that's the thing I feel
like now I finally understand how
like my parents felt when
I would like go to them
and being like, can you help
me with this math equation?
It's like, you, you
finished school. Right?
You've done this before.
And my parents were like, I
don't know how to do this.
I'm like, what do you mean?
You don't know how you did this in school?
- I think, I can't even remember
like having passed my
master's in engineering.
I probably can't remember
how to do basic trigonometry now.
- Dude if someone came
with like some 10 year old
came up to me and was like
can you help me solve this
long division equation?
I'd be like fuck.
I don't know how the fuck to do this.
- I'd probably research real quick.
Am sure I can get the answer to you.
- Let me Google it real quick.
Like I totally get that now.
- Yeah, because I remember
as a kid, you're just like,
"how can you not know this?
You're an adult.
You know, everything you
learned this before."
- You know how see the
fucking like Facebook quizzes
that pop up, they're like you know,
it'd be like different tanks of water.
It'll be like, which
one will fill up first.
But that was like, literally
like part of my fluids exam.
We had stuff like that.
And I'm like,
back in the day I'm sure
I can answer that too.
But right now I got no fucking idea
because I don't remember what
the fuck it was all about.
All right.
Well, I guess we have nothing else to talk
about today, boys.
So handed off to you, the host Garnt.
- Or we just, we just,
(laughing)
- I can't remember how we ended up.
- I'm satisfied.
- I've seen enough Trash Taste time.
Am satisfied.
- To the patreons.
- I've talked enough.
I'm satisfied.
Hello patreons.
Thank you for being a patreon.
Here are all your names.
- You guys are beautiful, amazing.
- Look at all your beautiful faces.
- Hey, if you'd like to support us
go over to patreon.com/trashtaste
Also follow us on Twitter,
The subreddit
and let's do us on Spotify
if your head, our face.
- I just feel like Joey
does it so much better
than either of us, because he's just
like ingrained that
into, up into his head.
- I literally just like mentally.
I just like press a button on a place.
- I just choose not to.
- I mean, Joey does it for me
every time and I'm just laying
and I just, just let,
just let Joey don't do it.
- Hey man don't fix something
that isn't broken, you know?
- Yes. Do everything that Joey says.
And did, you mentioned
that we have a Twitch channel as well?
- Oh yeah.
We haven't mentioned that.
We have a third channel now.
- Oh yeah.
Trash Taste After Dark.
It used to be unofficial.
And now it's official.
I know that confused a lot of people.
- It's, it's very, it's very confusing
because there are some
channels out there that aren't
official and there are
some channels out there
that are official.
I mean, we were like, let's
set the record straight.
We have three channels.
We have this one that you're currently on.
We have Trash Taste Highlights
and we have Trash Taste After Dark.
Anything else is unofficial.
- Where we will be
uploading our Twitch stream.
Basically after dark is literally
just a VOD of outage, Twitch streams.
- You know, there might
be other like, you know
bullshit content as well.
But for the time being
all of the Twitch Fords.
Oh yeah, by the way, follow
us on Twitter as well.
At Trash Taste podcast,
we'll be doing like semi-regular string.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
We have some stream ideas, no
promises, but it's just there.
- Just follow us there
- Anyway. That's it.
Connor has been very tied today.
- No, I was good the first hour.
And then I'm just like, bro hit me.
- This is, this is how I've
seen you for the past week.
Kinda of has been addicted to
apex for like the past month.
And every time I see him,
he doesn't just do himself.
Every time I see him, he
he just comes in and be like, guys
I was streaming till like 4:00 a.m.
- I wasn't streaming yesterday.
I'm just tired.
(laughing loudly)
- Most of the time he doesn't even stream.
He just plays and I'm just like fine.
- Anyway, that's it from us.
So we'll see you guys next time.
- [All Three] Bye.
(bright upbeat music)